LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WEAR MASKS TO BE WORN BY
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM INSIDE
THE BUILDING. IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY. FOR TESTIMONY TODAY-
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
A BILL PLEASE LISTEN TO MY
PROBLEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT APPROPRIATE TIME
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ONCE
THE ROOM YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING
IN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. OUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IS
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL. WE WILL INVITE
TESTIMONY FROM THIS REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION AFTER WE TAKE
TEST MY PHOTOS INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE LISTEN FOR
THE PROMPT. FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES WE'RE USING THE
MODERATED THE TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESSCAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE S. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO WHEN
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING. ON BEGINS THE BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
WILL CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND. NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST. OR YOUR SMART
DEVICES PLEASE NOTE THAT IF
YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS. PROVIDING
TESTIMONY YOU WILL REMAIN ON
THE LINE THE LINE. AND WE'LL
NEED TO MUTE YOUR DEVICE INTO
YOUR CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL MY
OFFICE. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE THREE NINE FIVE EIGHT. MY
STUFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU
WE ALSO ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE USING METHODS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WILL
ALSO BE MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
WE STILL FACE. OKAY NOW LET'S
COVER THE GROUND RULES FOR
APPROPRIATE CONDUCT. ASSEMBLY
HAS EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE
EMPLOYER PROCEEDINGS THE LAST
FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK ABUSING TO PUT IT ON.
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
AND THREATENING ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER THAN
TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION ON MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL. ANY DISCO THE
DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS THE
NEED TO SUB DOES DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS ARE
HEARING PROCESS- DIRECTING TO
STOP IN THE MORNING THE
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN THE REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE WILL ALSO
DEFICIT DOCUMENT THE ON RECORD
BECAUSE WE DOCUMENT ON THE
RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED
IN THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT AND I MAY
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT CONDUCT
DOES NOT STOP THE REQUESTED
SYSTEMS OF THE SERGEANTS. HI WE
HAVE ELEVEN MY ITEMS TODAY ON
THE AGENDA. TWO OF THESE ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. I DON'T
NUMBER TWO S. B. A. ONE THREE
BY THE GOVERNMENT THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
FOUR ONE FOUR SENATOR JONES. WE
WILL HEAR OTHER HALL ALL OTHER
BILLS IN ORDER SHOWN ON THE
AGENDA UNLESS OTHERWISE NOTED.
WE WILL TAKE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TO IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES EACH PROVIDED TESTIMONY.
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THE NAME ORGANIZATION IN
A POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
WE'RE LIMITING THE TIME FOR
THESE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE. THIS MEANS WE WILL TAKE
CALLS FROM ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES AND THEN
THE OPPOSITION FOR FIFTEEN
MINUTES IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY WITHIN
THE FIFTEEN MINUTE PERIOD.
PLEASE SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
HELLO THERE IS NO QUORUM AND WE
WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. OUR FIRST BILL TODAY
WILL BE- FIRST WILL HELP ITEM
NUMBER THREE. SB FIVE FIVE TWO
SENATOR HERTZBERG WELCOME THANK
YOU. OTHER MOUTHFUL IT WAS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR. HERE'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE. FIVE FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NINETEEN OF
NINETY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
I'M A FEW DECADES. INTRODUCED
THIS A REALLY COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE- DEALING WITH THE
EXTRAORDINARY DROP TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE LARGER ISSUE OF
THE NEED FOR CONSERVATION SPENT
A LOT OF TIME WITH THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR PUT A PACKAGE TOGETHER
THAT WAS PASSED BY BOTH HOUSES
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN WORKING QUITE WELL. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO
THAT AS WE FACE THIS WORST
DROUGHT FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE MEMBERS I'D PUT THE
RECORD TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
ACCORDING TO THE DATA THAT I
HAVE THIS IS THE WORST DROUGHT
IN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS. SO CLEARLY IT REQUIRES
OUR GOVERNMENT'S ATTENTION TO
DEAL WITH THIS IN EVERY WAY
POSSIBLE. NOW THE- MEASURES
THAT ARE SOME OF OUR FRIEDMAN
NIGHT IT AUTHORED WITH A SERIES
OF CO AUTHORS AND JOINT
AUTHORS. DEALT WITH LARGER
WATER DISTRICT IN FACT 75% OF
THE DROUGHT IMPACTED PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS. ARE FOR WATER
SYSTEMS THAT SERVE LESS THAN A
THOUSAND PEOPLE. MINISTRATION
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING ON
THIS IT DIDN'T HAPPEN WE'VE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL 75% OF THE
DROUGHT IMPACTED PEOPLE PEOPLE
HAD WATER BOTTLES OF SOME OF
THE SNOW. DELIVERED IN THEIR
COUNTY SAW AND TULARE WE'VE
SEEN OTHER PLACES. HORRIBLE
OUTCOMES THINGS YOU JUST CAN'T
IMAGINE HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IS JUST LIKE THE
PLANNING THAT WE REQUIRED UNDER
THE TWO MAJOR BILLS THAT WERE
INTRODUCED SB SIX OH SIX. AND
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. WE'VE
EXTENDED THOSE PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE SMALLER
DISTRICTS- SIZE FIFTY STRUCTURE
1-522-005-0000 NINE HUNDRED
NINETY NINE CUSTOMERS. TO
BASICALLY FILL OUT THE PIECE
THAT WAS MISSING. NOW I'M NOT
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS-
AGRICULTURAL AND- COMMUNITY
HAVE THE SMALLER DISTRICTS MY
DISTRICT BASICALLY IS ALMOST
ALL THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF WATER AND POWER. BUT I AM
DEEPLY IMPACTED PERSONALLY BY
THE NEED FOR AN INTELLIGENT
THOUGHTFUL WATER POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SEE THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT NEED FOR OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE. AND EVEN
THOUGH WE REPRESENT CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AS LEGISLATORS WE
ARE ALL PART TOGETHER. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS AND WATER IS
SUCH A CRITICAL ISSUE. AFFECTS
ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE AND
INTELLIGENT POLICY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS A- PORTENT IS
IN THE BOOKS IN PERIL IN LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER THE PART. IS
WE TRY TO. RE THINK THROUGH HOW
WE DEAL WITH WATER POLICY IN
CALIFORNIANS FOR THOSE REASONS.
I ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND WE'VE GOT A COUPLE
OF WITNESSES ON THE LINE. I'M
HOPEFUL OKAY I BELIEVE IF IT
ALL WORKS OUT WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES- WE HAVE DANIELLE
BLESSED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ON THE PHONE. AND CENTER
SCHABAS FROM SAFER ADVISORY.
BOARD MEMBER. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. THE
AIRLINES ARE OPEN THANK YOU-
I'LL GO I'LL GO FIRST AND GOOD
EVENING CHAIRED MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DANIELLE BLACK WHITE.
CALIFORNIA YES AT LEAST THAT
THE SENATE WE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES AND PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE TO. DROUGHT IS HERE-
WILD AND IT'S GETTING WORSE-
WHILE LARGER WATER SYSTEMS HAVE
ROBUST WATER SHORTAGE DID YOU
SEE PLANTS THAT HELP THEM IN
THEIR CUSTOMERS PREPARE FOR
INTO WERE DRY TIME THINK
LOOTING THAT'S FINE. SYSTEMS
LASSEN THREE THOUSAND
CONNECTIONS AND COMMUNITIES
RELY ON DOMESTIC WELL DO NOT
HAVE TO KEEP THE PLAN FOR TIMES
OF DROUGHT. SB FIVE FIVE TO THE
OUTGROWTH OF GWR'S. COUNTY
DROUGHT ADVISORY GROUP REPORT
AND INCLUDES REASONABLE AND
CRITICAL PLANNING TOOL. IT WILL
START THE FOXES THEN THE
COMMUNITIES DOWN A PATH OF
WATER SHORTAGE IN DROUGHT
RESILIENCY. WITHOUT PLANNING IN
PLACE FOR SMALL SYSTEMS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE RISK OF
GOING WITHOUT WATER TO MEET
THEIR BASIC HOUSEHOLD DRINKING
WATER NEEDS YOUR NEXT DROUGHT.
IS DIRECTLY THREATENED
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SECURE
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER FOR
ALL. WE CAN DO IT WE CAN DO
BETTER AS A STATE TO PREVENT
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE LAST
DROP FROM HAPPENING AGAIN. SB
FIVE FIVE D. REPRESENTING
DORIC- EFFORTS TO HELP PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON DRINKING
WATER FOR AREAS MOST VULNERABLE
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. WE UNDERSTAND COUNTIES
HAVE CONCERNS WITH RECENT
AMENDMENTS BUT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THEM IT'S THEIR
FOR HERTZ BURKE TO FIND A
PRODUCTIVE PATH FORWARD. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS POSSIBLE WILL NOW
HAVE MISSED SHOTS. HELLO I YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SANDRA
CHAVEZ AND I AM A DOMESTIC
WHILE RESIDENTS FROM THE RURAL
COMMUNITY OF WHAT QUARTER BILL
LOCATED IN CLARE COUNTY. I
ADVOCATE FOR THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER AS A MEMBER OF. COMMUNITY
WATER THOUSAND HEARING WOULDN'T.
YEAH PLEASE CONTINUE MS CHAVEZ.
WHAT I WILL CONNECTION AND ON
THE SAFER ADVISORY GROUP AND
THE MEDICAL RESIDENT FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS I HAVE
EXPERIENCE HEAD ON THE CRUEL
OBSTACLES THAT DROUGHT CAUSES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES. IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
DOMESTIC WELL THAT PROVIDES
WATER FOR MY FAMILY IT'S WILD
WENT DRY WE STRUGGLED FOR EIGHT
MONTHS WITHOUT RUNNING WATER WE
SCAVENGE AROUND LOOKING FOR
RESOURCES AND LOOKING. FOR HELP
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY. AND
HAVING WATER TO PROVIDE FOR MY
YOUNG FOSTER SIBLINGS AND LOOKS
MORE LIKE STOCK MY FAMILY LIVES
UP. MY HAD TO BUY LARGE WATER
TANK TO FILL WITH WATER FROM
THE HOMES OF FRIENDS THERE ARE
OTHER SOURCES THAT WE FOUND IN
THIS TIME OF NEED. MY DAD SIX
SIXTY EIGHT TRIPS A DAY FILLING
UP THE TANK AND WHEN HE CAME
HOME WE HAD TO QUICKLY FILL UP
BUCKETS AND DESIGNATE HOW MUCH
WOULD BE SPENT ON DRINKING.
SHOWERING COOKING CLEANING AND
OUR LIVESTOCK SO THAT HE COULD
LEAVE ON TIME TO GET ANOTHER
LOAD OF WATER. BUT A SUMMARY OF
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT DROUGHT
HAD ON MY FAMILY AND COMMUNITY.
EVERY COMMUNITY COUNTY AND
WATER SYSTEM MUST HAVE A PLAN
TO PREVENT THESE. HARSH IMPACT
THAT WE STATE FOR OVER. EIGHT
MONTHS. I AM HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE BY
YOU BECAUSE I AM CONFIDENT.
THAT THE PACKING OF THIS BILL
WILL DIMINISH THE LEVEL OF
TERROR AND TRAUMA THAT SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS FEEL. WHEN THEY
HEAR THE WORDS DROUGHT. DROUGHT
EMERGENCY. WATER SHORTAGES. DRY
WELL I THANK HER. SB FIVE FIVE
YOU IS THE ASSURANCE THAT
FAMILIES IN RURAL AREAS NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEIR FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES WILL BE PROTECTED.
IN THE NEXTRA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOT TAKE-
WELL WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
I HAVE TO. REGISTER CATHERINE
FRIEDMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AND SAID NAWG. RURAL COUNTY.
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR TO
LOOK AT AFTERNOON BOTTOM SHARED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME'S KATHERINE FREEMAN AND
I'M HERE TODAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF REEVALUATING OUR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL BASED ON THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS. AND COMMITMENTS
MADE BY THE AUTHOR AND A STAFF.
I WANT TO FIRST START BY
THINKING SO MUCH THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK WITH OUR
COALITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH A SPELL. WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF AND THE SUPPORTERS
FOR WORKING WITH US TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BILL AS
OUTLINED. IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS AND
HAVE MUCH IN COMMON. AS
DISCUSSED IN MANY KNOWLEDGE
WITHIN OUR LETTER COUNTY
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
COUNTY CHILD ADVISORY GROUP.
THAT REPORT MAKES SEVENTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
DROUGHT RESILIENCE BUT FOR ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY. IN PARTICULAR
RURAL COMMUNITIES BUT AS THE
REPORT STATES IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TIME EFFORT AND FUNDING TO
CARRY OUT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. HOW WE GATHER
INFORMATION ABOUT- DRY WELL
DROUGHT MATTERS MAY APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOW FOR
STOCK DECLARATION OF THE
PURPOSE OF THE DRY WELL. WHICH
WILL RELIEVE THE COUNTIES OF
THE LIABILITY OF DETERMINING
CAUSATION. IN FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER STAFF
AND SUPPORTERS TO DISCUSS HOW
TO REPORT TRY WEALTH AND JOB
REPORTING. THE CURRENT VERSION
OF THE BILL WOULD HAVE ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES CREATE
SEPARATE WEBSITES REPORT TRY
WELL SOME VERY FAR A PASSION.
FOR WORKING ON LANGUAGE WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO
CONSOLIDATE THIS INFORMATION ON
THE EXISTING DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES MIGHT TRY WATER
WELL WEBSITE. COUNTY HAVE BEEN
PARTNERING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS- WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
GET INFORMATION OUT- IN AND IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS ABOUT
THIS VOLUNTARY TOOL. FROM THE
COUNTY SPECIFICALLY DIRECT
RESIDENTS TO THAT SITE AND THE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED MUCH
THE SAME MANNER BUT THE BILL
SUGGEST JUST ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO FOCUS STATE ATTENTION
FUNDING. AND EMERGENCY SERVICES
THANK YOU SETBACK AREAS OF THE
STATE. THE FROM OUR PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH AUTHORS
STAFF. IT SOUNDS LIKE WILL
CLOSE AN AGREEMENT ON THIS IS
SHE- AND COUNTY IS. VOCAL ON
NONPROFIT ALSO ARE ABLE TO. AND
FROM THE WEB. WE HOPE THAT. TO
ON THE- WITHIN. A COMMUNITY
OVER THE COUPLE OF YEARS.
INCLUDING WE- THAT WERE. IS
AFTER MUCH OF. THAT THE AUTHOR
AT THE COMMITTEE STOP WITH HELP
OF. SURE WE STRONGLY. STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT EFFORTS TO
PLAN FOR PREPARE AND MANAGE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS. I THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
COUNTY. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN- NOW I HAVE MISTER
KNOCK. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SAGAR CANNOT
GET ON TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
AUTHORS OFFICE AND THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL. OUR CONCERN IS
MOTIVATED BY THE LIMITATIONS
AND STAFF TIME AND RESOURCES
BETTER COUNTY SPACE
PARTICULARLY SMALL ONE WORLD.
AS WELL THE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE WORK WITH AUTHORS OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
PROVISIONS OF CONCERN THAT'S
THE PATCHWORK THE SENATORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN TAX. AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH ADDRESS MANY
OF OUR CONCERNS AND GIVE US A
LONG WAY THEIR MARCHES
CAPLINGER SAID- THE OFFICES
ACT. AND WE HELP WITH CONTINUE
DIALOGUE WITH DOCTOR'S OFFICE
AND THE COMMITTEES- THAT WE
MIGHT REACH RESOLUTION IN THE
COMING WEEKS THNK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO A WITNESSES IN. SUPPORT IN
THE AUDITORIUM. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY. ON THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY AREA. HEARING NONE
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR GAP-
SB FIVE FIVE TWO ON THE LINE.
FOUR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S.
TO BE FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO AND
LINE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY YEAR
MIKE IT UP AND- MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BLIND BLIND. SIX
HUNDRED FORTY. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS NATALIE UP ESCALATE THE
ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
RECALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BLIND. SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU JOHN
MEMBERS WOULD UTILITY ABOUT
WHAT THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER
COMMUNITY BASED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
TWO I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
REGISTER THE SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
FINDING YOUR COMPANY. AND CLEAN
WATER ACTION I WANNA GO TO
COLLEGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE LINE IS. SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE. SIX FIVE
NINE YES SIX FIVE NINE WEAKENED
AREA- GOOD IS THIS WHAT WE
OPPOSE SB NINE AND TEN. I KNOW
THIS CURRENTLY IS S. B. FIVE
FIVE TWO YOU CAN CALL IN WHEN
WE DO THOSE BILLS THANK YOU.
ARE YOU DOING. LINE AT SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE. WHILE YEAH
YOU DON'T UPLOAD A DIFFICULT
BUT THREE HELLO THE NUMBER IS
THE LAND THAT IS MANDATE YOU
NEED A MOTHER BUT I DON'T OPEN
AT ANY POINT THAT AIN'T GOING
BE SHALLOW FORD ABOUT UP OF
WITH THAT IT'S A VERY SINGLE
CORBELS THERE IS A LACK OF
MONEY THAT ANYBODY COULD GET A
FIFTY DOUBLE. MODUS. OPERANDI
BUT I DO THAT METHOD YET
PROGRAMS ON THANK YOU FOR THAT
MILLIONS. THIS IS. WELL I AM
SIX HUNDRED EIGHT. SHE'S
CATHERINE THE GARBAGE NEARLY OF
FOR AND TO WE STAY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIX
HUNDRED SIX. THIS IS WHAT MY
DATA- WOULD ALLOW THE QUOTATION
COMMITTEE WATER CENTER AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU BLIND. BY.
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR. FIVE
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SANDY HUBBARD REPRESENTING JUST
MYSELF FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. SIX HUNDRED TEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN BRUCE MY NAME IS
STEPPING A LITTLE SIGN NOW ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
LEADERS NETWORK REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN CITIES AND COMMUNITIES
AND TULARE KERN AND KINGS
COUNTY WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. LINE.
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE- ALL OF THE BEST HENRY
FROM LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF- SB. FIVE
FIVE. I FORGOT THE NUMBER FIVE
FIVE TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LAKE WE'VE MAKING
THOSE MISTAKES TO THE- END OF
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO NOW
MOVE INTO WITH- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY HERE
IN THE AUDITORIUM. A REMOTE
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSING S. B. FIVE FIVE TWO.
HEARING NONE OPERATOR WILL GO
TO THE LINES AGAIN THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION OF SP FIVE FIVE TWO.
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AT THE B. FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENT COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- SINCE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT
NOW SENATOR WE WILL BE-
BRINGING THIS BACK I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR YOU DOES
THE- ARE YOU GOING TO I JUST
WANT TO. MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS WHICH WE
HAS A SEMI CLOSE LIKE SEPTIMUS
IS DISCUSSED WITH STAFF GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUB I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THE
BILL THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WERE
BROUGHT FORWARD. I CALIFORNIA'S
ALL L. REAL NODES IN RING
ANOTHER DROUGHT AND WE SHOULD
BE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
AVOID AS MANY OF THE
CONSEQUENCES WE FACED DURING
THE LAST DROUGHT. I KNOW YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS ON THE REMAINING
CONCERNS WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY ACCEPTED I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL- ONCE WE
GET A QUORUM- WILL LAST FOR TO
DO BE DO PASSED- THE TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SO THOUGHT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO YOUR
SECOND BILL YOU GUYS MAKE IT
ONE FINAL COMMENT. NO SORRY
YEAH I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
WAS MOVED BY SANDRA CHAVEZ'S
COMMENTS ABOUT THE TERROR AND
TRAUMA OF THE DROUGHT SHE
REALLY PERSONIFIED IN A REAL
WAY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
CORRECTING THIS. AND TELLING
THE STORY ABOUT HOW MANY
GALLONS OF WATER AND HOW MANY
BUCKETS OF WATER THEY HAD
ALLOCATE IN THEIR HOME THERE'S
NO BETTER WAY TO TELL THE STORY
AND I. WANTED TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH HER. THANK YOU.
TWENTY WELL TAKEN. ALL RIGHT-
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
OKAY. LET ME TELL YOU WHY I
THINK THIS LAWS NEEDED AS WELL.
YOU KNOW I WAS LIKE MY OFFICE
LIKE WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND WHY WE USE THIS
LAW. IT'S ALWAYS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT IS PUSH
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BY-
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY WHICH
BUILDS HOMES HOMEOWNERSHIP NOT
RENTAL PROPERTIES. BUT
HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR FOLKS. AND SO
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW THAT WE
CREATED IN SOME PEOPLE HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE- EXPERTS
HOUGHTON- WAS CREATED SOME
YEARS AGO BUT THERE WAS A- A
HOLE IN THE LAW IF YOU WILL.
WHERE THERE WAS A LIMITATION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT- THE- THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AS A
QUALIFIED NOT FOR PROFIT COULD
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY
COULD ACTUALLY CHOIR THE LAND
ACQUIRED THE PROPERTY. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY BUILT GIVE IT TO
SOMEBODY ELSE. IF FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP SO THIS IS A- A
FIX IN THE LAW THAT WE
UNFORTUNATELY LEARN THE HARD
WAY IS WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE- MYRIADS OF WAYS TO
DEAL WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE'RE FACING. AND THIS IS
JUST ONE ANOTHER SMALL STEP IN
THIS GIANT EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE FACING.
WITH A GROUP IS CREDIBLE AND AS
BRILLIANT AS THE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY IN THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. I SAW IN THE NEWS RELEASE
THE OTHER DAY THAT PRESIDENT
CARTER AND ROSALYNN CARTER JUST
CAME OUT TO A COMMUNITY IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND PLANES.
TETHER TWENTY FIVE HOMES WHAT
AN EXTRAORDINARY STORY. TO TURN
OVER THE WITNESSES. RIGHT-
OPERATOR WE ARE LOOKING FOR
JAMES GERARD FROM THE HABIT OF.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY FROM
ORANGE COUNTY HE WILL BE ON THE
PHONE. JAMES GERARD LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JAMES GERARD AND I AM THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
COORDINATOR AT HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY OF ORANGE COUNTY IN MY
ROLE I WORK WITH CITIES AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP FIND
NEW WAYS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
AND WORKFORCE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. HABITAT'S
CONTINUALLY LOOKING FOR
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO BUILD
NEW AFFORDABLE HOME OWNERSHIP
HOUSING. WHEN HABITAT AND NOT
THE DEVELOPER THEMSELVES ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS IS TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL DEVELOPERS USING THE
DENSITY BONUS AND ASSIST THEM
IN PROVIDING THE AFFORDABLE
UNITS REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW.
ESSENTIALLY HABITAT WOULD
ACQUIRE THE AFFORDABLE UNITS
BILL UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS
AND SELL THEM TO A QUALIFIED
HABITAT PROGRAM FAMILIES. UNDER
OUR MODEL HABITAT REQUIRES THE
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND PLACES ARE
FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL COVENANT
ON THE HOME THIS ALLOWS HABITAT
TO PURCHASE THE HOME BACK FROM
OUR PROGRAM FAMILIES WHEN THEY
ARE READY TO PURCHASE A FAIR
MARKET RATE HOMES. WITH THE
EQUITY ACCRUED UNDER THE
HABITAT MODEL HABITAT
THEMSELVES THE HOME TO A NEW
INCOME QUALIFIED PROGRAM FAMILY
THIS FURTHER FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL. INSURANCE OUR HOMES
REMAIN AFFORDABLE IN
PERPETUITY. THESE PARTNERSHIPS
COULD HELP HABITAT BUILD MORE
HOMES FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE
UNDER THE CURRENT DENSITY BONUS
LAW LANGUAGE HABITAT IS NOT AN
ELIGIBLE PURCHASER AND THE
NONPROFIT WHICH HAS LIMITED OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE QUALITY
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES TO
LOW AND VERY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. CAN HAVE A CHAT TAKES
POSSESSION OF THE UNIT IN THE
INTERIM WHILE WE QUALIFIED
BUYERS. LOCALJURISDICTIONS
HAVE BEEN HESITANT TO APPROVE
THIS MODEL. THIS IS SLOWED
HABITAT'S ABILITY TO PARTNER OR
TO BUILD THESE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH DEVELOPERS AND TO PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOME OWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITY. SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT PROVIDE THE CLARIFICATION
ON WHO WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
QUALIFIED BUYER AND THAT
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS ALIKE
HABITAT CAN HELP MAXIMIZE THE
FOR SALE AFFORDABLE UNITS BILL
UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT FOR SALE UNITS
BILL UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS
WON'T BE LOST TO MARKET RATE
WHICH UNDER CURRENT LAWS
TRIGGERED INTO POND RESALE
THEY'RE NOT SOLD TO ANOTHER
INCOME QUALIFIED BUYER WITHIN
SIX MONTHS. SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT AND SHARED THE HABITAT
COULD PURCHASE THOSE UNITS. TO
MAINTAIN THEIR PORTABILITY.
PROVIDING LOW IN VERY LOW.
INCOME FAMILY WITH US AND
DECENT PLAY TO CALL HOME FOR
THESE REASONS I HAVE LISTED.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR GERARD DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
ANYBODY HERE IN THE AUDITORIUM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK LOOKS
LIKE I HAVE ONE SPEAKER WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX FAR AS
A STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THERE'S NO OTHERS SPEAKERS HERE
ARE THERE ANY ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. HEARING NONE OPERATOR
THERE ANYWAY BY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO. AND A LINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. MATANCERA MEMBERS
AREN'T ABLE ONE PAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BLIND BLIND
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. I'M
SURE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT.
ANNOUNCER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EMILY GABEL LUDDY TASK NEAR
BURBANK CIVIL CALIFORNIA EAST
VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS SANDY HUBBARD AND FOR THIS
CALL I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LIVE. FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE. ELIZABETH HENRY OF
ST LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SOME TWENTY. THANK
YOU. ALAINA SPECTATORS AND.
FIFTY NINE- IS IT TIME TO
OPPOSE SB NINE AND TEN I DO SO
CONFUSING SIX IT THINK WHICH TO
ME IS THAT THIS IS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BE PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO CALL BACK RIGHT CURRENTLY WE
ARE ON SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
IT'LL BE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
BEFORE WE REACH THOSE OTHER
BILLS THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH. BLIND
AT THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO. HI
THERE MY NAME IS A MAJOR FACTOR
IF YOU'RE A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS WONDERFUL BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME READ THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE AUDITORIUM. SEEING
NONE ANY WITNESSES AND REMOTE
TESTIMONY. HEARING NONE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SB. SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
SEVEN TO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS COMING THROW I'M
SORRY WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. AN
OUTLINE IT SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M CALLING TO PLEASE URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON A FEW BAD
BILLS SB EIGHT EIGHT IT
REQUIRES NO OF PORTABLE
OPERATOR- WE NEED TO THIS IS
THE BEST BESEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE OING
TO MOVE ON- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. TO
THE SENATOR SAYING NONE- AGAIN
WE ARE UNABLE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AT THIS TIME SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HI I
WOULD HAVE JUST A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ONE IS A- POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AGAIN I SAW.
DID KNOW SHE WAS GOING TO
APPEAR THE FORMER MAYOR OF-
BURBANK AND MADE GABEL LUDDY
WHO'S WONDERFUL HUSBAND FOR
DECADES WAS. ONE OF THE LEADERS
OF THE CARPENTERS AND GOOD GOOD
PEOPLE AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW AS WE ENGAGE IN
THIS EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
FOLKS THIS IS ANOTHER FIX IS
NECESSARY AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT- YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN DO IN MY
JUDGMENT. THAT HELPS
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN EVERY PROGRAM
AVAILABLE IS BETTER WE AVOID
THIS EXTRAORDINARY
DETERIORATING AFFECTED THE RICH
POOR DIVIDE THE POLARIZATION
TRAITS HOME IS WHERE THE WEALTH
IS AND IT GIVES PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. NOT BE PORTING
MORE GAMES IN EQUITY IN SOME
WELL SOY THIS IS JUST LOOKS
LIKE IT'S A SMALL THING BUT
EVERY HOUSE ONE BY ONE ALL
MATTERS TOWARD HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND THAT'S WHY I DECIDED TO
CARE THIS MEASURE. FOR HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY ESCRIBO YOU KNOW
SENATOR YOU MADE A COMMENT THAT
I JUST WANTED TO SIT SAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
AS MANY TIMES AS WE TRY TO BE
THE PERFECT BILLS IN THIS
BUILDING. AND THE TWO THAT
SOMEONE WHO KEEPS TRACK OF THE
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIX
THOSEBILLS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE AND GET THOSE
IMPLEMENTED APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND FOR
SUCH AN ORGANIZATION LIKE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. IT'S A
GREAT PARTNER WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND AGAIN WHEN WE DO
MOVE FORWARD I WILL IT. IS TO
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
CUSHION. OKAY LET'S SEE HERE I
HAVE. TOM. OKAY WE ARE WE ARE
JUMPING OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A FEW AUTHORS HERE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
CURRENTLY- IDM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS S. B. EIGHT WE HAVE
HAD SOME PHONE CALLS ON THAT.
AND THEN WE WILL HEAR S. B. TWO
NINETY IS THERE BOTH SENATOR
SKINNER'S BILL SO AGAIN IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING
TO CALL IN. WE WILL BE DOING S.
B. EIGHT. AND AFTER THE
COMPLETION OF S. B. IT'S
TESTIMONY WE WILL THEN MOVE ON
TO S. B. TWO NINETY. I KNOW
IT'S A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING TO
EVERYBODY THIS EVENING DURING
THIS THIS WAY BUT- WE'RE DOING
OUR BEST. SO GOOD EVENING
SENATOR AND THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB EIGHT WELCOME I THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I FIRST WANT TO SAY I
THANK YOU I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY
THE TERM CONCURRENTLY AS IT
RELATES TO MEETINGS- AND- I'M
ALSO WORKING CLOSELY. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FURTHER CLARIFY
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS BEING THE
CITY OF LA IN THE PLANNING OF
CONSERVATION LEAGUE- THE- WE'RE
WORKING ON TRYING TO MAKE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS TO ASSIST. THEM
AND- WE WILL WE WILL GET THERE
I'M CONFIDENT AND I THINK THEY
ARE ALSO- WHAT SB EIGHT DOES IS
WE HAVE A VERY SUCCESSFUL BILL
THAT WE PASSED THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACT. WHICH WE ARE PUT A
SUNSET ON- NOT EXPECTING A
PANDEMIC AND NOT KNOWING THAT
THE PANDEMIC WOULD AFFECT- IN
FACT WE SHUT DOWN CONSTRUCTION
SHUT DOWN MANY OF OUR PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS A MANY OF OUR
ZONING BOARDS. AND SO-
BASICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS EXTEND THE SUNSET OF S. B.
EIGHT SO THAT WE CAN GET OF
SKEWS ME OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
ACTOR SB EIGHT EXTENDS. THE
PROVISIONS OF THAT BILL FOR
FIVE ADDITIONAL YEARS TO TWENTY
THIRTY- NOW. JUST FOR MY- THAT
WHAT THE HOUSING CRISIS ACTED
WAS RECOGNIZED THAT. WE WILL
HAVE THAT CERTAINTY HELPS
HOUSING PROJECTS AND THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ZONING. FOR THEIR-
LAND USE POLICIES IT SIMPLY
SAYS. IF I HOUSING APPLICANTS
SUBMITS A PERMIT PROPOSAL FOR A
PROJECT THAT MEETS YOUR
EXISTING RULES THAT INCLUDES
DESIGN REVIEW THE WHOLE BIT IF
IT MEETS YOUR EXISTING RULES
THEN PLEASE PROCESS IT IN A
TIMELY MANNER HOLD NO MORE THAN
FIVE PUBLIC HEARINGS. CERTAINTY
SO THAT THOSE YOU'VE ALREADY
GONE THROUGH THE WHOLE SECRET
PROCESS YOU'VE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDER
AND PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS TO
GET YOUR S
E POLICIES AND SUCH SO IF
THAT HOUSING APPLICANTS MEETS
THOSE RULES LET'S GIVE THEM
SOME CERTAINTY AND LET'S GET IT
MOVING. NOW THE REASON OF
COURSE WERE TRYING TO GIVE IT
THE BENEFIT OF A FEW MORE YEARS
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE CONSTRUCTION
STARTS DOWN RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT
THE LOWEST NUMBER OF A NEW
CONSTRUCTION FOR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING THAT WE'VE HAD IN A
DECADE D. O. IN AND THAT'S BEEN
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS THE ONLY
SEGMENT OF HOUSING THAT UP TO
GET A LITTLE BIT IN THIS YEAR
WAS SINGLE FAMILY HOMES SO
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO- MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IN A VERY SIMPLE
WAY. WHICH IS LET THOSE. HOW
DOES HOUSING APPLICANTS WHO
MEET THE RULES- CAPS SOME
CERTAINTY. SO- I WOULD LIKE TO
TURN TO MY WITNESSES PEDRO
CALVO FROM THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND TOM LIMóN FROM
THE CITY OF OAKLAND HE'S A
PLANNING COMMISSIONER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
UP OPERATOR WE ARE LOOKING FOR
TOM LIMON AND A PEDRO VOLVO.
BOTH LINES ARE OPEN THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING CHAIR
AGUIAR-CURRY VENTURE LACKEY-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK I'M ATABOUT BOND
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. I THANK HER SKINNER WHICH
WILL CONTINUE THE SUCCESS OF SB
THREE THIRTY BY MAINTAINING
PREDICTABILITY AND LOCAL
HOUSING APPROVAL PROCESS SEES.
THE CORPORATE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY EXACERBATED
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY AND HOUSING IS
ESSENTIAL FOR CORPORATE
RECOVERY AND HAVING AN
AFFORDABLE AND STABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME THREE THE SPACE
FAMILIES GOING TO HEAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
LIKE ALL OTHER DEVELOPMENTS
NEED TO ABIDE BY LOCAL RULES
YET IN THE PAST PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN DELAYED SOMETIMES FOR
YEARS DUE TO ARBITRARY CHANGES
AND LOCAL REQUIREMENTS. EVEN
AFTER A PROJECT HAS BEEN
APPROVED SO WHAT WHAT IF THE
THREE THIRTY DOLLARS IS A
CREATES PREDICTABILITY AND HOW
THE APPROVAL PROCESS I HOLDEN
DOUBLE SPENDING ONCE A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN APPROVED
AND CREATING PREDICTABLE
PIPELINE PLEASE PROCESS PLEASE
HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL TO GETTING
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOMES BUILT TO GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE- WE HAVE SHIRLEY
CHISHOLM VILLAGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE THEY WEREN'T
ABLE TO SHAPE ALL. SIX MONTHS
OFF THE PROJECT- BECAUSE OF SB
THREE THIRTY AND IT'S
LIMITATION ON THE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS- THANK YOU STATE
CONTINUES ON ITS PATH TO
RECOVERY IT IS CRITICAL THAT
LEGISLATORS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
HELPING AND I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT SB EIGHT TO
MAINTAIN PREDICTABILITY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN APPROVAL
PROCESS THE- THAT IS SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. AND WE
THOUGHT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW. US
TAMI MONA VALE BOTH. YES- GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TOM KNOWN AND ON A PLANE
COMMISSION THE CITY OAKLAND AS
WELL AS THE- DIRECTOR OF THE
CUT. WE IS THE ONLY. MULTI OR-
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER ALL KEY
PLAYERS FROM THE POLICY
BARRIERS THOUSAND. AT SENATOR
SKINNER MENTION IN OUR OPENING
REMARKS CALIFORNIA IS VERY MUCH
STILL IN A HOUSING CRISIS
BECAUSE WE FAILED TO BUILD
ENOUGH HOUSING FOR DECADES. AND
THE CITY PLANNING COMMISSIONER
AND HOUSING PROFESSIONAL I KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW CHALLENGING AND
OFTENTIMES PROHIBITED. IT CAN
BE TO PRODUCE HOUSING UNITS ONE
CITIES CHANGE THE RULES MIDWAY
THROUGH A DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
CERTAINTY IS A MUST OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON PAPER ALREADY
ALLOW ABOUT TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION MORE HOMES. BUT THEY
HAVE YET TO BE COMPLETED. THE
LATEST SHOW UP AT INCREASES TO
THE COST OF THE UNIT WHICH IS
PASSED ON TO BUYERS AND RENTERS
SOME OF THE PROJECT EVEN
REACHES COMPLETION. MANY
DEVELOPERS DON'T HAVE THE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT THE EXTENDED
TIMELINE AND CANCEL THE
PROJECT. I WITNESSED MANY
PROJECTS IN THE BAY OUR- REGION
GET STUCK IN THE PROJECT REVIEW
PIPELINE IS SUBJECTED TO DOZENS
OF HEARINGS AND CHALLENGES.
WITH THEIR LOANS ARE THEIR
EQUITY AND DELAYS AND I DON'T
REQUIREMENTS TRIBE OF POPS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
PROJECTS UNDER THE PROTECTION
OF THE STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW
A CRITICAL WORKFORCE HOUSING
PROJECTS ARE FREQUENT TARGETS
OF MAJOR LOCAL OPPOSITION. THAT
CAUSED. DELAYS AND EVENTUALLY
KILL HOUSING. SB THREE THIRTY
THE HOUSE CRISIS ACT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PROVIDED THAT
CERTAINTY. AND COMBINED WITH
OTHER STATE HOUSING LAWS HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING
MANY NONPROFIT. MAKES INCOME
AND MARKET RATE HOUSING
PROJECTS APPROVED. WITH ONLY
FIVE HEARINGS NOT INFINITE
HEARINGS. AND A MORE RATIONAL
COMPLETENESS PROCESS AT THE
FRONT END SB EIGHT BUILD UP ON
THE PROGRESS OF SB THREE THIRTY
AND PROVIDES REASSURANCE AND
BELL PEPPERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALIKE. THANK
STANDING THE SUNSET DATE TO
TWENTY THIRTY AND CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL TERMS THE GREEN LIGHT
FURTHER HOUSING PRODUCTION. I
EXTENDING THE BENEFITS IN
IMPROVING THE CLARITY OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS ACTS CALIFORNIA
WILL CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE.
TRUE VISION. BY TAKING A
PRUDENT AND MUCH NEEDED TO STOP
AN ATTACK WHEN STATES I'M GOING
HOUSING CRISIS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION REGISTERED BUT IF
YOU BRING A CHANCE. OKAY
HEARING NONE. WE'RE GOING TO-
WITNESSES HERE IN THE
AUDITORIUM IN SUPPORT. OUR
STORES WE HAVE THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THEIR
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE THE
AUDITORIUM SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES THE REMOTE TESTIMONY.
HEARING NONE- OVER THERE
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR S. B.
EIGHT. IN SUPPORT OF. FOUR
EIGHT. OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO LINE. FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT. WE THE FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALAINA SIX HUNDRED TWENTY NINE.
GOOD EVENING AND IF THERE'S A
CAMANCHE OCCURRED CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF BILL IN
SUPPORT OF THE FEET THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FINEST. SIX HUNDRED
ELEVEN. GOOD EVENING UNTIL THE-
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT FOR THANK YOU.
ALAINA. SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DOESN'T MATTER THAT
LIGHT HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANISATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT CALIFORNIAN THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AND PAYMENT TO GO
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION KNOWN AS FAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALIGHT AT. SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. MEMBERS
THANK YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI TOPICS WE LIKE TO
THINK THAT AND UNDERSTAFFED YOU
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THE FILM LOOK FORTY HEARING
CONVERSATION TO ADDRESS IF YOU
ARE OUT AND CONCERNED AND
SENATOR MENTION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINUS. SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX. ANYTHING CHAIR
NUMBERS KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE THE SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD EVENING
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP MORE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LIMA. SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT. MARK
STIVERS THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FINEST SIX
HUNDRED NINETY. WAIT WHILE THE
COMPANY HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MINUS. SIX
HUNDRED FORTY NINE. BLANCHARD.
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE. LINE SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE. WHY NOT
SEVEN HUNDRED. HE LEFT A LEGACY
OF CRANKS ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME IN SUPPORT. LINE
IT IS SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT.
SO CONFUSING YOU'RE NOT
FOLLOWING THE AGENDA WHERE ARE
YOU AT I'M TRYING TO OPPOSED.
TEN AND NINE AND EIGHT. SKEWS
ME CONFUSED THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON S. B. EIGHT. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THROW THAT ONE
TERRIBLE PLEASE NOTE THE RECORD
I. THINK YOU. BLINDNESS. SIX
HUNDRED NINETY ONE. THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR FOR FEELS STILTED
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR. HELLO THIS
IS MICHAEL DR AYE AND CAPITAL
VALLEY AND- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. EACH LINE. SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE. GOOD
EVENING AGAIN I'M SURE MEMBERS
OF THE MAN THAT LIKE A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS- I APOLOGIZE I FORGOT
TO ADD STAND HEALTH PROPERTIES
AND SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NO LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED TO ONE HE GOOD EVENING
CURRENT MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES
ON BEHALF OF THE POLITICAL
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OPERATOR
MUST CURRENTLY WE'RE GOING TO
DO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY IN THE AUDITORIUM
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY IN
OPPOSITION AT THE REMOTE
TESTING SITE. HEARING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPERATOR WE
ARE LOOKING FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. S. B. EIGHT AGAIN.
ARE WE ARE LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT WHICH WOULD
BE NUMBER SEVEN ON THE AGENDA.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
U. S. B. EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO LINE THREE
HUNDRED NINE. I MEAN BROKEN ON
THE HALF TO SPEAK DISTRICT OF
THE SHIRLEY CHISHOLM VILLAGE
WHICH IS NOT AN SB THREE THIRTY
PROJECT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLIND IS SIX HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN. HELLO HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILL BE
A COMPLETE SHOCK ON BEHALF OF
THE MEDIA HILLS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY. ANY GEGEN FROM
HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN COURT OF
COMMUNITIES UNITED NEIGHBORS
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT
LOS ANGELES CHIEF LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST DRAWING OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT THANK YOU. ONE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT. I'M CAPPY
NIGHT FRONT DESK PARKED ON A
MONICA- IT HAS NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND SO WELL I WERE
OPPOSED TO IT. THANK YOU. NINE
OF. FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR- HI
THIS IS JENNY HUBBARD ON BEHALF
OF VALLEY BILL INSURANCE AGENTS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS MOBILE CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT. THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVEN HUNDRED FOR. THIS
IS CATHERINE BRIDE WINDERMERE
VALLEY PROPERTIES FROM PLASTER
COUNTY- IT STRONGLY OPPOSED. SB
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE SIX
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR BUT- THE
ONE THAT TIME MCELROY IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES. PLEASE HOLD THIS
BILL THIS WILL REMOVE LOCAL
DEMOCRACY. I'M TOLD AT EIGHT
THANK YOU. WINDS THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU JOSEPH
MCCARTY FOUR HUNDRED OWNERS OF
RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
ONLY ONE YEAR IN THIS BILL
SHOULD NOT ALREADY BE EXTENDED
SINCE WE HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT HOW
EIGHTY YOU LAWS ARE ALREADY
AFFECTING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
PAGE OPPOSES NO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LINE IS SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX. DAVID WEEKLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL TALLY LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA PARK AVENEL OWNERS
ASSOCIATION YEAH AND- STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. A LINE IS. SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO. FIND SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO. LINE. SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE. GOOD EVENING
THERESA MORRIS MOTOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED SB EIGHT AND
I WOULD ASK THAT IT BE VOTED
AGAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLIND OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE. RECALL WITH LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND CULTURAL ACTION
NETWORK OPPOSE LIMITING
COMMUNITY VOIGTS OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE. SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY. EIGHTY OF SOUTH
LOS ANGELES RESIDENT I OPPOSE
THANK YOU. WINDS. FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT. ELIGIBLE LEADING
THEIR PROGRAMMING LEVEL
CALIFORNIA I'M FERNANDO VALLEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE. ELIZABETH HENRY SAVE
LAFAYETTE LEVEL CALIFORNIA AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT AND THEY'RE
RIGHT THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY IN THAT THANK YOU.
LINE. SIX HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN.
ELIZABETH BLAIR SANTA MONICA
NEIGHBORHOOD NO MONTH FIVE
THOUSAND. RESIDENTS OPPOSED SB
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY ONE. NINE
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE. HELLO
HELLO HELLO WE CAN AREA. OKAY
YES MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND I'M
CALLING IN REFERENCE
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU JUST LOOK
AT THE BILL AND WHO DRAFTED IT
AND THE PEOPLE THAT SIGNED IT
BACK IT WE SHOULD ALL KNOW IT'S
CRIMINAL. HI JOHN THE- THANK
YOU. BLINDNESS. SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE. JILL STUART SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND- ANGELENOS
BETWEEN AND LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
HE OPPOSE EXTENT EXTENDING IT
FOR FIVE YEARS IF YOU WANT
ACTUALLY YOUR CALL COULD TAKE
ONE YEAR LINE IS SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
MARCY HE JEREMY ALSO GETS.
BATES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE H. B. EIGHT.
FACEBOOK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE AT SIX HUNDRED FORTY SIX
NO I DIDN'T ACT FOLLOWING-
REPRESENTING INDIAN LAW- WE'RE
ACTUALLY AT THE PORT IT'S
AMENDED ACCORDING TO OUR LEAD
THAT WE JUST SAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT. HI YOU'RE NOT
ASKING PEOPLE NAMES AND YOU'RE
YOU'RE HANGING UP ON PEOPLE
YOUR PARTY HUNG UP ON ME ONCE
AND PEOPLE CAN'T GET LINES AND
THEIR FAMILIES PLEASE PUT YOUR
AND YOU SAY YOUR NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT IN YOUR POSITION
PLEASE. PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO. ACT AND YOU'RE NOT
FOLLOWING THE AGENDA. AND THIS
IS SO. CAN YOU PLEASE PUT YOUR
NAME IN A POSITION. ON THE BILL.
WELL I IN AT. SEVEN HUNDRED
THREE. JERRY TAUGHT STERN
SPEAKING FOR- EAST BAY
ADVOCATES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS A REMINDER YOUR NAME YOUR-
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ONLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SIX. HI THIS
IS LESLIE BASKET WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FINE. SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTEEN. THIS WALLACE FROM THE
MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENT IT'S
NOT WORKING NOT ONLY ARMENIAN
AT LEAST. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE SEVEN HUNDRED TEN. I THINK
HE CALLED MOUNT SHASTA AT
REPRESENTING WATER FLOWS FREE
CITIZENS FOR QUALITY GROWTH
AND- NOT TESTED TOMORROW
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN. WINDOWS
HELLO REPRESENTING DOWNTOWN
LONG BEACH RESIDENTS I AM
DIRECT DIRECTLY OPPOSED TO SP
EIGHT THANK YOU. WINDS SEVEN
HUNDRED NINE. HELLO THIS IS
TRACY DOYLE ELDORADO COUNTY
REPRESENTING IN THE OLDER OUT
OF COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
TO THE SENATOR. I SEE NONE- WE
ARE UNABLE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AT THIS POINT SINCE WE
DO NO HAVE A QUORUM- BUT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE HERE
MORE THAN WELCOME TO DO SO-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR AND I THINK THAT THE
WORLD SOME OF THE OPPOSITION.
REFERENCE THAT THIS DOES NOT
BENEFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
FACT IT IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT TEND TO HAVE THE
LONGEST- TIME PERIOD BEFORE
THEY GET THEIR APPROVAL AND AS
A RESULT MANY DO NOT GET BUILT
BECAUSE THEY ARE DEPENDENT ON
TAX CREDITS AND OTHER TYPES OF
FINANCING THAT BY THE TIME THEY
FINALLY GET THE GREEN LIGHT.
THAT IS NO LONGER THERE
FINANCING IS EITHER NOT
ADEQUATE ARE NO LONGER
AVAILABLE SO THE MOST THE
SUCCESS STORY SO FAR HAVE BEEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
BUT- WITH THAT THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ALSO MENTION IS THAT THE
ORIGINAL HOUSING CRISIS ACT DID
PASS ON WITH A BI PARTISAN VOTE
AND THIS EXTENSION SB EIGHT PAT
OF BIPARTISAN VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE- THANK YOU
SENATOR- REALLY WORK-
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON YOUR
DOING ON ADDRESSING THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS. THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACT HAS ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED SOME EARLY SUCCESS
IN REMOVING BARRIERS TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND I APPRECIATE YOU
MAKING THE COMMENTS OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN AND HOW THIS ALL
WORKS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR THE PANDEMIC DEPRIVE US OF
THE UP TO SEE THE LAW FUNCTION
IN NORMAL ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THE LAST FOR
AT LEAST TWO YEARS. I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD SO THE PROVISIONS OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AS YOU INTENDED ON
THE MOTION WILL BE TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ONCE
WE GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FIVE SENATORS
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR ITEM
NUMBER. EIGHT SB TWO NINETY.
THANKS MUCH THIS IS THE EXACT
BILL THAT WAS ON YOUR FLOOR. AT
THE LAST DAY OF SESSION IT HAD
SIXTY SEVEN FIVE VOTES- ON IT
JUST BECAUSE OF THAT TIME
PERIOD ON THE LAST DAY OF
SESSION. THE SENATE WAS NOT
ABLE TO TAKE IT OUT- I CAN GO
INTO THE DETAILS BUT I THINK
MOST OF YOU'RE FAMILIAR. AND I
WILL TURN IN THE STATE NOW TO-
BRANDON YOUNG. WHO MY WITNESSES
THE FROM THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND PATRICK KENNEDY
FROM PANORAMIC INST. INTERESTS
THANK YOU OPERATOR OPEN THE
LINES FOR MR YOUNG AND MR
KENNEDY. OKAY THANK YOU THIS IS
PATRICK KENNEDY CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. OH GREAT MY NAME IS
PATRICK KENNEDY AND I AM AN
INFILL DEVELOPER- IN THE BAY
AREA I FIRST USED DENSITY BONUS
LAW ON BERKELEY I THINK WHEN-
SENATOR SKINNER WAS A COUNCIL
MEMBER THERE AS A MATTER OF
FACT IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
AND I USE IT AGAIN IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN IT TOOK
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE LAW IN
GETTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILT OUT AT VERY LOW COST
BECAUSE IT'S IT REQUIRES A SET
ASIDE A- BELOW MARKET RATE
UNITS. IN A MARKET RATE
DEVELOPMENTS AND AT NO COST TO
THE CITIES- THE NEW OF
PROVISIONS OF SB NINETY. EXTEND
THE BENEFITS- THE DENSITY BONUS
ACT TO STUDENTS- AND ENCOURAGE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF STUDENT
HOUSING SOMETHING THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED CERTAINLY IN
BERKELEY AND MANY OTHER CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- I READ
RECENTLY THAT THE- THE
CHANCELLOR SAID THAT 40% OF THE
STUDENTS AT UC BERKELEY. CANNOT
LIVE WITHIN TWO MILES OF CAMPUS
AND HAVE TO LIVE- AT
DESTINATION I HAVE AT THAT
LOCALES VERY FAR REMOVED FROM
FROM- FROM THE CAMPUS ITSELF-
THIS LAW IS A SIMPLE- AND I
THINK- POWERFUL FIX THAT WILL.
UTILIZE DENSITY BONUS LAW ON
BEHALF OF STUDENTS THAT ARE- IN
SORE NEED OF HOUSING AS ARE
MANY OTHERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PASS IT AS AS PROPOSED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR KENNEDY ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES RIGHT HERE THANK
YOU. MISTER YOU YOU MAY MISTER
BRANDON YOUNG HOUSE BRENDAN
YOUNG I'M SORRY SO- BRANDED
LIKE SPEAK. HI THERE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. MY NAME IS
BRANDON YOUNG AND I WILL BE A
SENIOR UC BERKELEY NEXT YEAR
AND ALSO SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF
THE HOUSING COMMISSION FOR THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENT BODY.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE ASUC REPRESENTS MORE
THAN FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS AT
UC BERKELEY THANKFULLY EACH OF
WHICH DOESN'T HAVE TO TESTIFY
WE WOULD LIKE TO LEND OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL TO
NINETY WHICH WOULD STRENGTHEN
THE STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW. IN
PARTICULAR WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
CONCESSIONS FOR AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE DENSITY
BONUS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MENTION THAT FOR NEARLY EVERY
POLICY INTERVENTION USED TO
EITHER PROTECT RENTERS ARE
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
STUDENTS ARE EXCLUDED PART OF
THAT IS THE NATURE OF A
CONSTANTLY TRANSITORY RENTER
POPULATION. MAKING RENT
CONTROLLED UNITS CONSTANTLY
RESET TO MARKET RATE IS ALL
DISTRACTED STUDENTS ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR TRADITIONAL DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FOR THE DEMOGRAPHIC CIVIC
LEADERS CALL THE FUTURE LOCAL
AND STATE HOW THE POLICY IS
SPELLED STUDENTS DRAMATICALLY.
THAT'S WHY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SURVEY ADMINISTERED BY THE
CAMPUS SO THAT 10% OF STUDENTS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND GENERALLY AT
UC BERKELEY. IF YOU COULD SEE
THE WAY STUDENTS CRAMMED INTO
ONE OR TWO BEDROOM APARTMENTS
IN ORDER TO AFFORD RENTS IN
BERKELEY. THE IMAGERY WOULD BE
SHOCKING ON THE LEVELS OF JACOB
REES PHOTO ESSAY HOW THE OTHER
HALF LIVES DEBATING TENEMENT
HOUSING IN EARLY TWENTY TH
CENTURY NEW YORK CITY. WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
SENATOR SKINNER'S CONTINUED
EFFORTS TO INCENTIVIZE
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING.
NEARLY THREE YEARS AFTER ITS
PASSAGE HOWEVER NO PROJECTS IN
THE CITY OF BERKELEY HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE 35% DENSITY
BONUS PROVIDED BY S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN THE INITIAL BILL
SAYING THE RAFTER FOREMOST IN
HOUSING DENSITY BONUS LAW.
ADDING ADDITIONAL CONCESSION
WHICH IS USUALLY SOMETHING LIKE
WITH THE PARKING ARE BUILDING
FORM CONSTRAINTS WOULD HELP
MAKE SUCH PROJECTS MORE
ATTRACTIVE. THAT MAY ONLY BE
INCONSEQUENTIAL INCREMENTAL IN
THE FUTURE WE HOPE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING. FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COMPATIBILITY CHARTER AND
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING MS. ANYWAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ON THE LINE I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED.
WE'LL ASSUME WE DO NOT- WILL
MOVE ON TO A WITNESSES IN OF
THE AUDITORIUM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TO
NINETY. THANK YOU. ALEX CHARLES
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHERS IN THE AUDITORIUM
WILL MOVE TO REMOTE TESTIMONY
IS THERE ANYONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY AT THE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
NINETY. HEARING NONE OPERATOR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THAT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWO
NINETY. MARK COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF AT B. TWO NINETY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. LINE
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE OF MY
COULD OPEN. WILL GREENBERG
PROBLEM THE VIGIL LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO NON CANNOT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. LINE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR. HELLO. ABOUT SAVAGE.
FIVE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. BUT A
PLACE REPRESENTS THE- MINUS.
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY NINE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND IF
THERE'S A POLITICAL
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT AT THE
END EACH YEAR NINETY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR CAN YOU
CLEAR THE ONE LINE THAT'S- I
ALWAYS. YEAH I JUST NEEDED
THEM- THE PARTY BACK TO OUR
INVITED. RESCINDED YEAH WELL
THEY'RE THEY'RE MUTED NOW.
ONLINE TO CONTINUE THANK YOU.
LINE FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT MAY FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. SIX HUNDRED TWENTY THREE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS QUESTION MATTER NOT AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FAVORITE DISCO
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA GREENBELT
ALLIANCE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION AND AREA COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BLIND FIVE HUNDRED NINETY NINE.
MADAM CHAIR LOREN GABEL AND
FAIR REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. A LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTEEN. BUT MANAGER
MEMBERS THE PHILADELPHIA CLAIMS
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHEN MEMBERS
I'M JENNA PATIENT ARE YOU STILL
A STUDENT COMPANIES AND
COUNTRIES BUT MY ON THE HOP IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO NINETY.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE. LINE SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE. LINE. SIX HUNDRED
NINETY ONE. YEAH THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR BETWEEN BITES-
REPRESENTING FIELD SEVEN
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO NINETY THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETEEN. GOOD
EVENING GOVERNOR SAID ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. LINE.
SEVEN HUNDRED ONE. GOOD EVENING
KAREN MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY TWENTY TWO
AN EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG
SUPPORT EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
NINE SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BLIND
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
TRACKING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHTLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ONE REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR BOTH SB EIGHT AND TO NINETY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I AM LINE
SEVEN HUNDRED TWELVE. ALL RIGHT
OUR CURRENT FROM LOS ANGELES
ALL RIGHT. WELL I WOULD WORK
THIRTY FOUR DIFFERENT- SERVICE.
AND ALL AFTER. ORGANIZATIONS
ARE VERY TRUMP THANKS A LOT
THANK YOU. AND MADAM CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THEIR ANY WITNESS OPPOSITION IN
THE AUDITORIUM. SING NOT ANY-
REMOTE TESTIMONY FOR OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO NINETY. ALL YEAH.
ARE THERE HOW MEANT TO NOT
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO.
BLIGHTED. SIX SIX HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN. OTHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WHY AND. SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE. HI THIS IS HERSH FROM
CATALYST IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED
NINE. I NEED BROKEN SUNSET
PARKSIDE DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LINE SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY AND GEGEN HOLLYWOOD
FRANKLIN COURT OF COMMUNITIES
WITH UNITED NEIGHBORS LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO NINETY
THANK YOU. OFFLINE SEVEN
HUNDRED TEN. ET COLD PRESENTING
EARTH COMPARED TO MOBILE TV
WATER CLOSE VERY SHASTA
TOMORROW AND CITIZENS FOR
QUALITY GROWTH LAST BUBBLE
CALIFORNIA FROM THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU BEST. WHY IS THAT
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO. AMY
JUST FACTORY THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED OWNERSHIP REVERE
HOMEOWNERS. CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS THIS WATERS DOWN THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW SO STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. LINE AT SIX
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR. ONE AT A
MACRORIE STOP ALL ANGELES
CALLIE UNITED NEIGHBORS
GRAYBURN AVENUE BLOCK CLUB
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. TWO
NINETY THANK YOU. FIND SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. YES TIMES
REPRESENTING THE MIRACLE MILE
RESIDENTIAL ASSOCIATION OF LOS
ANGELES AND AFFILIATED WITH THE
MOBILE CALIFORNIA. OPPOSE SB
TEN NINETY. THANK YOU. FIND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE YEAH ONE
BOB. DONNAN LINE. SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE. FINE OF THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE- RECALL
WITH LITTLE CALIFORNIA AND
CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK DON'T
DILUTE DENSITY BONUS SUPPOSED
TO NINETY THANK YOU. A LINE OF.
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE.
ELIZABETH HAMMERING SAVE
LAFAYETTE UNITED NEIGHBORS AND-
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL IS
DISINGENUOUS AND IT'S INTENT
AND CONTENT. LINE AT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTEEN. HELLO THERE
GOOD EVENING BETH WALLACE FROM
MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION OF SILICON VALLEY
AND WE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. A LINE
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. HIS
JOSH WALLACE FROM THE MAGNOLIA
OF RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU HERE. LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
THREE BOB. ARE YOU TOSSED ACT
EAST BAY ADVOCATES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE OPPOSED
TO NINETY THANK. THANK YOU.
PINE SEVEN HUNDRED FOR. CCAP
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO COUNTY
REALTOR WHENEVER VALLEY
PROPERTY STRONGLY OPPOSED.
FIFTY TO NINETY THANK YOU BLIND
LINE SIX HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. BY
DAVID WEEKLY AND THE LOS
ANGELES WESPAC CALIFORNIA
CITIES FOR LOCAL CONTROL PARK
AVENUE OWNERS ASSOCIATION KELLY
AND- CATALYSTS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
HUNDRED NINE. ARTICLE ONE-
PROGRESSIVE ASIAN NETWORK FOR
ACTION SAVE OUR SENIORS OR SOS
ST LOS ANGELES STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU. BLIND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT KATHY KNIGHT SANTA
MONICA- THIS IS THIS REDUCE
PORTABILITY REQUIREMENTS ON A
POLE AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. ONE SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE. HI MARCY YELLOW THIS IS
NOT THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY FOR
STUDENTS STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU ALL IN ALL THANK YOU NINE
SEVEN HUNDRED NINE. TRACY A
WELL CALLED I HAVE TO TELL ME I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED I'M STILL
THINKING SO PLEASE DON'T HANG
UP THIS IS AGENDA TWENTY ONE
NONSENSE AND YOU'RE JUST TRYING
TO BLUR THE LINE BETWEEN. THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
LINE. FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR.
HI THIS IS CANDY HUBBARD ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY VILLAGERS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE SB TWO
NINETY THANK YOU. LINE. SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. SAN IN THE
LINE WESTWOOD HIGHLANDS SAN
FRANCISCO. I OPPOSED BECAUSE OF
THE DENSITY BONUS CHANGES THANK
YOU. NINE SIX HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN. CLAIRE SANTA MONICA
NUMBER NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS OPPOSE SB
TWO NINETY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THREE.
MY DAD DIED CITY OF ALAMEDA
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO NINETY. THANK YOU.
LINE SIX HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
GOOD EVENING TRICIA KRANESHARES
SANTA MONICA NORTHEAST
NEIGHBORS THE CITY RECOGNIZED
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
AFFILIATED WITH LEVEL
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE ON SB TWO
NINETY THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE BEFORE I
MOVE ON I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO THAT WE MAY BE ABLE
TO MOVE YOUR BILL ALONG OKAY-
SECRETARY CAN YOU TAKE THE ROLE
PLEASE. CURLY HAIR AGUIAR-CURRY
PRESENT LACKEY LACKEY PRESENT
ROOM HERE WILL PRESENT
BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS
THREE OF US CARE THREE OF US
PRESENT. ROBERT RIVAS YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL YOU CAN
HELP PERSON NUMBER SIX. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM I DON'T
THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO SO WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THIS BILL DO I HAVE A
MOTIONS. EXACTLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM MOVED INTO
SECONDED BY RIPOSTE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS. WELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK SKEWS
ME THANK YOU- CHAIR MEMBERS- IT
WAS INTERESTING TO HEAR THE
COMMENTS PERHAPS- THE CALLERS
DON'T SUPPORT STUDENT HOUSING
BUT THE MAIN CHANGE THIS BILL
MAKES IS IMPROVING THE ABILITY
FOR THE DENSITY BONUS TO BE
USED FOR HOUSING THAT WAS BUILT
FOR STUDENTS. AND- WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK%
YOU SENATOR SKINNER IT'S
IMPORTANT THANK ONCE AGAIN
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
HOUSING I BELIEVE THIS MEASURE
MAKES RESPONSIBLE JUSTICE TO
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW AND I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORTED TODAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
I'M LUCKY ALL RIGHT. I BLEW. I
BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS
THREE OF US WHOSE RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. WELL RIGHT NOW.
BERMAN BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH NO. SIX MORE WE
HAVE SIX ONE AND WE'LL WAIT FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO COME BACK IN-
SHOULD WE GIVE HER THE BILL
OVER HERE. WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND
DO YOUR OTHER BILLS TO INSURE
HERE BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T MIND
WHY DON'T WE- THERE IS- WE NEED
AN ENTERTAINING MOTION. FOUR A
SENATOR SKINNER'S S. B. EIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
SECRETARY. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY HAI LACKEY LACKEY
ABSOLUTELY FIVE LITTLE FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ALMOST THREE OF US THIS
RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I'M A FELLOW. I
WILL GO ON SIX ONE OKAY ONCE
AGAIN SIX WON'T KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU COMMITTEE OKAY IT
LOOKS LIKE I HAVE TO DO AUTHORS
HERE DO THEY WANT TO FLIP A-
COIN AND- MISTER HUESO CENTER
HUESO. I WAS GONNA NO I'M NOT
GONNA HAVE RUSSELL. NOW I JUST
WANT TO MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT TO
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING TO GET ON.
GENERALLY WE STAY IN LINE WITH
OUR AGENDA BUT DUE TO THE LATE
OF THIS MEETING AND GETTING
MEMBERS HERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN ACCOMMODATE WHOEVER
WAS IN THE ROOM AT THE TIME. SO
AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
OUR NEXT BILL IS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SB SEVEN TWELVE SENATOR
HUESO. AGAIN IT'S ITEM NUMBER
HUESO SENATOR YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. SB
SEVEN TWELVE WILL RECTIFY YEARS
OF LONGSTANDING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE DEPRIVE NATIVE
AMERICANS FROM A FAIR PROCESS
IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO ACQUIRE
THEIR ASSISTANCE ASTRAL LANDS.
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED
FROM DECADES OF VIOLENCE
MISTREATMENT EXPLOITATION
ATTEMPT TO DESCRIBE THE
DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND DISPOSSESSION
OVENS AND SESTRA LANDS TO IN
TODAY IN OUR IN OUR- COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA- NATIVE AMERICANS
STILL HAVE THE HIGHEST HIGH
SCHOOL. DROP OUT RATES THE
LOWEST HIGH SCHOOL-
MATRICULATION RATES THE LOWEST
COLLEGE- AT. ATTAINMENT RATES-
AND- HAD THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATES REALLY MORE THAN AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINOS THEY
REALLY RANK- THE- THEY
OUTPERFORM EVERYBODY JUST OF
THE- ALL THE CATEGORIES THAT.
THAT THAT HAVE TO DO WITH THE
POVERTY AND- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S STILL NOT VERY WELL
KNOWN BY THE PEOPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO REVERSE THAT AND
I'M WORKING ON A BILL THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL WILL HELP. BE-
SOMETHING THAT ADDRESSES THAT.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND MOST
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF. THE
NATIVE PEOPLES CAME FROM WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S CALLED THE
GENERAL ALLOTMENT ACT OF
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SO
AROUND TIME- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
PUTTING ALL THE NATIVE
AMERICANS ON RESERVATIONS. WHAT
THE GENERAL A LOT THEY SO THEY
BASICALLY LOWER DEMAND TO
RESERVATIONS THEY WILL GIVE YOU
LAND LAND THAT YOU CAN FARM. IN
MANY CASES SOME OF THAT LAND
WAS ARABLE BUT THE GENERAL
LACHMAN AND IF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BASICALLY REDUCED. THEIR
LANDS TO LANDS THAT WERE NOT
FIREABLE NOT LIVEABLE. AND THEY
WERE REALLY REDUCED TO ONLY
RECEIVING GOVERNMENT AID. AND
AS A RESULT THEY SUFFERED FROM
THE WORST SCHOOLS THE WORST- OF
DIETS- NO- JOB OPPORTUNITIES
AND- BUT TODAY THERE IS SOME OF
THE POOREST CENSUS TRACTS IN
AMERICA. IN FACT THE NUMBER ONE
POOREST CENSUS TRACT IN AMERICA
IS A IS A NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TODAY
ALLOWS FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES TODAY TAKE BACK THOSE
LOST ANCESTRAL LANDS EVEN
SOMETIMES THE LANDS THAT WERE
PROMISED TO THEM ORIGINALLY.
THROUGH WHAT IS CALLED A FEEDER
TRUST ACQUISITION PROCESS THE
FEEDER ACQUISITION PROCESS IS A
REQUEST BY A TRIBE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZE THAT THE
LAND THEY ALREADY OWN. THANK
YOU. THE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THEIR RESERVATIONS FEEDERS
PRESS ACQUISITION PROVIDES THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN AN
EQUITABLE WILL OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUIRE THEIR TREASURED
TRADITIONAL LANDS UNFORTUNATELY.
IT IS UNCOMMON FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SUPPORT PETER
TRUST ACQUISITION THEY POSE IT
EVEN IF IT LOSES IF THE LOSSES
TO LOOK LOCAL JURISDICTION OR
MINIMAL OR TO NONE SOMETIMES
YOU GET MORE FEDERAL FUNDING
INTO A COUNTY BECAUSE OF THAT
AND SOMETIMES IS A BENEFIT. SO
BLANKET OPPOSITION POLICIES ARE
ARE REFLECTIVE OF HISTORICAL
STRUCTURAL RACISM. AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST NATIVE
AMERICANS. IT TO WHICH
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO PART SB SEVEN
TWELVE IS A BILL THAT WERE FOR
THEIR STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
RECTIFY PAST MISTAKES. AND
PROVIDE NATIVE AMERICANS THE
FAIRNESS THEY DESERVE AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND THAT
THIS BILL WOULD BASICALLY
PREVENT ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FROM TAKING. A POSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF AT THE EVENT
APPLICATION BEFORE IT EVEN
ARRIVES SO- I WANT TO THANK-
THE CHAIRMAN AND THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND- AND IDENTIFY IN SOME SOME
IMPROVEMENTS- THAT. NEEDED TO
BE MADE SO THAT WITH US FOR
BEEN VERY HELPFUL THIS IS I
THINK THIS BILL READY FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WE HAVE- CHAIRMAN BO
MAZZETTI WITH THE RINCON BAND
OF LOSING YOUR INDIANS. AND WE
HAVE A CHAIR PERSON ERICA PINTO
FROM THE FAMILY IN THE VILLAGE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS. IF YOU ALLOW MANAGER
ABSOLUTELY- GENERATOR OPEN THE
LINE FOR THE CHAIRMAN WAS
SETTING AND CHAIRPERSON PINTO
PLEASE. BOTH THE WITNESS LINES
ARE OPEN THANK YOU. YOUR
CURRENT TERM READY ARE YOU
READY TO HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. PLEASE FOLLOW UP
ABOUT YOUR PERSONALITY I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOUR COMMITTEE. AND
BETHANY IS UNDER WAY SO FOR
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT HAPPENED TO
MY PEOPLE. OUR ANCESTORS. ARE
PEOPLE RAN WAS TAKEN. WILL WE
EVER GET IT BACK PROBABLY NOT.
BUT SOME OF US HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. THE PURCHASE BY
BACK OUR OWN LAND. WE'RE
FORTUNATE THAT WE COULD DO THAT
WE DO NOT GO DOWN WHERE WE PUT
MORE RESERVATIONS BY LANCE.
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BUY BACK OUR
LAND. I IT NEXT TO VIRTUSA TO
OUR RESERVATIONS. WE DON'T GO
OUT SHOPPING PROGRAMS. WE HAVE
SPECIFIC PLAN THAT OUR
ANCESTORS WERE ON THAT MEANS
SOMETHING TO US THAT'S THE LAND
WE TRY TO GET BACK. FOR ALL OF
OUR PEOPLE. I'M I HAVE THE
HONOR TO SERVE AS THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL CHAIRPERSONS ASSOCIATION
ALSO. THIS ISSUE AFFECTS EVERY
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE OPPORTUNITY THE
FIGHT BACK FOR LANDERS EIGHT
YOUR. SAN DIEGO COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE HAD A BLANKET.
ORDINANCE TO OPPOSE. ANY AND
ALL BREED TO TRUST APPLICATION
THAT THE TRIBE TRIED TO BUY
BACK SOME OF THEIR OWN LAND. IT
WAS A BLANKET LOCAL. THE BOARD
RECENTLY CENTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS RISKY CHANGE THAT
POLICY. AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
SAYS. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOOK
AT THE TRIBE'S LOOK ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS. IF YOU ARE NOT
SURE ABOUT AB. SACRIFICIAL OF
THEIR OWN LAND YOU CAN ASK UP
THEY CAN ALSO SHARE WITH YOU
THE ECONOMIC IT ACT SAGA TO BE
IMPACTED TRYING TO PROVIDE SUCH
AS OURS WE PAPER TO SEND YOU
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS NO COST
TO TAXPAYERS WE STARTED AN
AMBULANCE COMPANY A SERVICE NO
COST TO THE TAXPAYERS. WE SPENT
DOLLARS A YEAR ON A FIRE
DEPARTMENT IT TRAVELS
THROUGHOUT THIS IN. A SPECIFIC
LOOK FIRE. YOU KNOW THAT NEEDS
TO BE RECOGNIZED. THIS BILL
HUNG. ALL FIFTEEN SECONDS.
BAKER DOES NOT. OPERABLE.
PROSPER ALSO STE- HARPER OPEN
DIALOGUE LOOK AT THEIR
APARTMENT THAT'S FEDERAL LAW
WILL SAY WELL THEY'RE CUTTING
OFF ANY CREDIT BUT THAT IS NOT
TRUE ANY SERVICE AND COULD
STILL PUT IN ANY COMBAT THEY
PREFER AND REFERENCE TO EIGHT
TRACKS FOR YOU TO TRUST
ACQUISITION OF BUYING BY THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN- YOU'RE A TIME
ALLOTMENT IS OVER I NEED TO
KNOW HOW CHAIRMAN CHAIRPERSON
PINTOS. PLEASE AND YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES PLEASE. HI GOOD
VENING HONORED CHERRY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ERICA PINTO AND I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING AS THE
CHAIRWOMAN. OF THE HUMBLE IN
INTELLIGENCE CALIFORNIA. I
TRIED FIRST I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR HUESO FOR HIS
COMPASSIONATE. THOUGHTFUL AND
RELEVANT COMMENT AT THE START.
OF MY TRIBE IS ONE OF EIGHTEEN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES. IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY- RESERVATIONS.
MY RESERVATIONS THE TIME ONLY
SIX ACRES OF LAND MAKING US ONE
OF THE SMALLER. RIVAL
RESERVATIONS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
ABOUT TWENTY MILES OUTSIDE OF
THE CITY OF DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO.
LIKE MOST IN THIS COUNTRY WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND THE
UNFAIR AND DISCRIMINATORY
PROCESS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS USED.
TO TRY AND BLOCK TRAVEL FEE TO
TRUST APPLICATION. INCENDIO
COUNTY MY TRIBE IN PARTICULAR
HAS FACED BLANKET OPPOSITION TO
OUR EFORTS TO EXPAND OUR LAND
BASED PER LONG STANDING COUNTY
POLICY AT SHERMAN MEANT THAT
INVENTION. COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
RECENTLY RESCINDED THIS POLICY.
WHICH WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
FROM I TRIED TO TRUST COULD
MEET ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HOUSING EDUCATION OR
CULTURAL CENTER HEALTH CARE
FACILITY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
CURRENTLY DO NOT EXIST.
CHAIRMAN OF ANY ALSO MENTIONED
THAT TRIED TO GIVE BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHERE WE ARE
WE HAVE GIVEN IN THE IN THE
FORM OF MONETARY DONATION
SERVICES EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SHARE PURPOSES AMBULATORY
SERVICES WE GIVE BACK THE FEE
TO TRUST PROCESS ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SUBMIT COMMENTS
OVER ANY POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
REGULATORY JURISDICTION. REAL
PROPERTY TAXES ESPECIALISTA.
UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RARELY SUPPORTS THESE
APPLICATIONS EVEN IF THE IMPACT
THE LOSSES ARE MINIMAL AND THE
BENEFITS THE TRIBE AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES ARE
SUBSTANTIAL. SADLY MY TRIBE HAS
BEEN SUBJECTED TO THIS TYPE OF
BLIND AND UNSUPPORTED
OPPOSITION IN SAN DIEGO FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS I HOPE THIS
WILL CHANGE SB SEVEN TWELVE
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
ENSURING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE BENEFITS
A FEW TO TRUST ACQUISITION.
HELP US REGAIN OUR ANCESTRAL
LAND HELP THE TRIED TO REGAIN
OUR LAND THAT WAS ONCE HOURS.
GIVEN THIS IN OUR HISTORY WE
STRONGLY ENDORSE SB SEVEN
TWELVE AND ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE PASSAGE TODAY I
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY HERE
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE'LL NOW MOVE INTO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I ONLY
HAVE ONE REGISTER THAT WOULD BE
CHRIS LEE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION. OF COUNTIES.
ON THE- GOOD EVENING CHER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CRITICALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REGRETTABLY WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON SB
SEVEN TWELVE I PERSONALLY WANT
TO SAY WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE P. TO
TRUST PROCESS AND THE ABILITY
FOR TRIED TO HAVE LAND TAKEN
INTO TRUST TO RESTORE THEIR
ANCESTRAL LAND BASES FOR ALL
THE REASONS POINT OUT BY THE
AUTHOR- IN THE PROPONENTS OF
THE LEGISLATION. WE DO HOWEVER
HAVE TO CONCERNS BOTH PRACTICAL
AND POLICY CONCERNED THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED IN PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT WE SUBMITTED TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE FIRST OF ALL
WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
POLICY STATEMENT THAT THE STATE
SHOULD REQUIRE LOCAL AGENCIES
TO TAKE AN INDIVIDUAL POSITION
RATHER THAN HAVING A POLICY OF
BLANKET OPPOSITION TO BE A
TRUST ACQUISITIONS WE HAVE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
CLARIFY WHAT COUNTY CITIES CAN
AND CAN'T DO- MAKE IT MUCH MORE
EXPLICIT IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL. THE SECOND ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH OTHER
PROVISIONS RELATED TO WHAT A
COUNTY OR CITY REPLYING TO AT
THE LOCATION OF COMMENTS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
THIRTY DAY DETOX NOTED MUCH TO
DO THE BILL GIVES YOU FIVE DAYS
TO REACH OUT TO THE TRIED TO
ASK FOR INFORMATION ABOUT
ECONOMIC IMPACT IN FIVE DAYS
FOR THE TRIED TO APPLY. THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A TIGHT TIME FRAME
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF A THIRTY
DAY PRIOD ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
STAFF PERSON WHO RECEIVED THIS
NOTICE CERTAINLY ISN'T GOING TO
KNOW WHAT THE ULTIMATE POSITION
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR
CITY COUNCIL THE CASE MAY BE
WILL BE ON THE APPLICATION
ESPECIALLY UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL ALTHOUGH THE BILL
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION RECEIVED FROM THE
TRIBE FOR STUDENTS THAT
CONSULTATION PROCESS. THAT'S
COMING FROM BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
THE FEE TO TRUST APPLICATION SO
WE PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
BETTER ALIGN A REQUIREMENT TO
CONSIDER THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
THE NEED FOR THE LAND THE OTHER
THING THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
TRIBE'S. REQUESTED A BUREAU OF
INDIAN AFFAIRS TO HAVE
WEDNESDAY INTO. WE THINK MORE
WORK OF WE ALL THINK IT MORE.
WAY RATHER THAN IN FOR. THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE RELEVANT THE
APPLICATION AT HAND REQUIRING
THAT IT BE SUBMITTED BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AS STATED IN
THE APPLICATION IS A BETTER WAY
TO APPROACH THIS ISSUE. WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ITS
CONSIDERATION OF OUR REQUEST.
AND HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
RESOLVE THESE CONCERNS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR LEAGUE WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN THE
AUDITORIUM IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN THE
AUDITORIUM. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. HEARING NONE
OPERATOR I'M LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN ONE TWO
AGAIN THE SEVEN ONE TWO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
THE ROW. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. I
SAID TO BE ONE MORE MOMENT
PLEASE. AN OUTLINE SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. YOUR CALL MY LINE
DURING TO NINETY AND YOU CUT
THAT LADY OFF AND YOU DIDN'T
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WAITED
AND YOU SHOULD LET PEOPLE EAT.
TOP OPERATOR THANK YOU. WE ARE
ONCE AGAIN WE ARE ON S. B.
SEVEN ONE TWO ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
IN SUPPORT THOSE IN SUPPORT. WE
HAVE ONE MORE COMIC COMING
THROUGH LINE IT IS. SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE. WHITE SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE- MY COULD OPEN.
LET ME I WOULD THINK YOU. YEAH
WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY NOBODY
GAVE ME A NUMBER SO I WASN'T
SURE IF IT WAS MY TURN TO SPEAK
I ASKING HER THERE WITH THE
LAST CALLER MY NAME IS OR SHALL
I REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE YOU GUYS ARE CRIMINALS
HOSTING MEETINGS AND MAKE
EXCUSE ME. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON.
I ADMIT I'M SURE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU- LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR S.
P. SEVEN TWELVE WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE- OPERATOR. ARE
COMMON IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO AND IT'S
GOOD SB. SEVEN TWELVE. BLIND
SEVEN HUNDRED NINE YOUR MIKE IT
UP. HELLO THE FUTURE IF YOU DO
WELL A LOT OF COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX. DAVID
WHEATLEY AS AN INDIVIDUAL HELLO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE BILL-
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
AND MADAM CHAIR THERE IS ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. IN
THE ASSEMBLY. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ALLARDYCE'S ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND THAT LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY FIVE.
WE LOST SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
DURING QUESTIONS. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL. NOW THE QUESTION
MADAM CHAIR BUT A COMMENT- I
SELDOM INDULGE MYSELF IN ANY
KIND OF A MOTION. ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I SUPPORTED
GREATLY AND JUST A QUICK LITTLE
STORY I WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FIFTY AND I GREW UP WATCHING
COWBOY AND INDIAN MOVIES. AND
WHEN I WAS NINE YEARS OLD I
ASKED MY MOTHER FATHER I SAID
WAIT A MINUTE ALL THESE WAGON
TRAINS COWBOYS AND INDIANS ARE
COMMON IN A JUST TAKING THIS
POOR INDIANS LAND. WELL YOU
KNOW AND MY PARENTS HAD NO
ANSWER. BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONDITIONED TO THAT TOO SO
WE'RE I'M GOING WITH THIS IS
THIS IS TO ME A RETURN OF LAND.
AND- IN MY THIS. I HAVE OR I
SHOULD I'VE TOLD THAT I THE
MOST GAMING TO IN CAL. AND IT'S
THE MIGHTY COOPER A NATION.
KNOWN AND- THEY'RE NOT CAN
STILL. THEY'RE NOT GAMING
TRIBES THAT SUPPORTED THEY'RE
MY FRIENDS I KNOW MOST OF THE
TRIBAL CHAIRS AND QUITE A FEW
OF THE- COUNCI MEMBERS AND
THIS IS VERY LONG OVERDUE. AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK IN
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. ROGER
THAT THANK HELL I'LL. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS MR VOEPEL- WE HAD TO
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND WE
HAVE A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
THANK YOU YEAH I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY I HOPE I CLARIFIED IN
MY COMMENTS I DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THE
MEN'S WERE NECESSARY TO. HELP
THE BILL GET A SIGNATURE SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT YES
THE GREAT THANK YOU I WAS GONNA
JUST- JUST MAKE SURE THAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON BEHALF OF OUR STATES
TRIBES EACH BE TO TRUST
APPLICATION SHOULD BE GRANTED
THE CAREFUL AND RESPECTFUL
CONSIDERATION TO DESERVES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. THE
ROLL. HI I BLEW. THE LITTLE
TIME THAT GUY I RUN HIGH LEVELS
I REQUEST IS BECAUSE I ROBERT.
RIVERSIDE LOOKED. HI THE BILL'S
AIDS THANK YOU RESULT THANK YOU
BILL ITSELF THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY HI LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ITEM NUMBER ONE.
WELCOME SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOUR- THREE AGAINST
THOSE THAT YOU'RE ON ON THE
LINE WAITING THIS WILL BE S. B.
FOR A THREE THE NUMBER ONE ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. AGAIN WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING A
COMPLETE ORDER THIS EVENING BUT
WE HAVE TECHNICAL AND NOT JUST
THE T. EVENING WE HAD TO KIND
OF GO OUT OF ORDER SO AGAIN WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT IN RHODE
MOVING FORWARD WITH S. B. FOUR
ZERO THREE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
START WHENEVER YOU LIKE THINGS
TO GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES IS A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGES
NINE THROUGH TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE OF AS WELL FOR
THEIR- DETAILED ANALYSIS- THIS
IS BILL SB FOUR ZERO THREE
WHICH WILL PROVIDE STATE WATER
AUTHORITIES WITH A WITH AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP
CALIFORNIA. FINALLY REALIZE THE
RIGHT TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. IN TWENTY FIVE
FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SB EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PROVIDED
THE STATE WATER BOARD WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO MANDATE
CONSOLIDATIONS FOR WATER
SYSTEMS THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THAT
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER. WELL THIS
AUTHORITY IS IMPORTANT IN THE
STATE'S SAFE DRINKING WATER
EFFORTS THAT CAN ONLY BE USED
IN SITUATIONS WHERE THE DAMAGE
IS ALREADY DONE. AND THE SYSTEM
IS ALREADY PROVIDING AND SAFE
WATER WHICH MAKES NO SENSE SB
FOUR OH THREE PROVIDES A
PROACTIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. BY EXPANDING- SB
EIGHTY UPON SB EIGHTY
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY.
MEMBERS WATER PORTS RECENTLY
RELEASED RISK ASSESSMENT
IDENTIFIED OVER SIX HUNDRED
SYSTEMS THAT ARE AT RISK OF
FAILING INDETERMINATE ONE THIRD
OF THE ACESTA MASTIC WELLS WERE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THOUSAND
WELLS. FOR CLASSIFIED AS HIGH
RISK TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
DIRECTING ATTORNEY FOR
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND JENNIFER
CLARY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN WATER ACTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
EXCUSE ME OPERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING. FOR MISTER CLAIBORNE
TO MISS CLARY. GOOD EVENING TO
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE MICROPLATE WALKING OUT HERE
ME YES WE CAN. RIGHT A
DIRECTING ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SAN JOAQUIN EAST COACHELLA
VALLEY. OR PROUD TO BE
SPONSORING SB FOUR THREE AND
THANK SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON ACCESS TO
DRINKING WATER. IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN A DIFFICULT AND DIFFICULT
FOR THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
HOUSEHOLD VERIFIED THE METRIC
WHILE IT CONSISTENTLY TO FIND
ADEQUATE QUANTITY OF STATE
DRINKING WATER- TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS. THE CHALLENGES SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS FAITH ARE ONLY
GETTING WORSE WHICH IS THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO INCREASING
GROUNDWATER POLLUTION EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS. AND MORE FREQUENT
AND SEVERE DROUGHT LIKE THE ONE
WE'RE IN NOW. AT THE SENATOR
JEFF MENTIONED THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD CUT COMPLETED A
DRINKING WATER NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. IDENTIFIED SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS AND NEARLY EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOMESTIC ABOUT THAT
ARE AT RISK OF FAILURE. ALSO
NOTE THAT APPROXIMATELY FORTY
SEVEN NEW WATER SYSTEMS GO OUT
OF COMPLIANCE EVERY YEAR. IN
ORDER TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
DRINKING WATER ACCIDENTS WE
MUST PROACTIVELY PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO AVERAGE WATER
SYSTEMS. AND WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE THIS BILL TAKING
VALIDATION OF WATER SYSTEMS AND
DOMESTIC WELLS WITH NEARBY
LARGER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE
WATER SYSTEMS. SB FOUR THREE
FAILED ON AT THE EIGHTY EIGHT
FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TO EIGHT IN
THE STRUGGLE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
STATE BOARD DID NOT HAVE ANY-EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO GET
STAKEHOLDERS AND COURT ROOM TO
TALK ABOUT CONSOLIDATION. IF IT
JUST HAS NOT YET FAILED EVEN IF
IT'S ENTIRELY PREDICTABLE THAT
IT WILL FAIL. IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO WAIT CURRENT SYSTEM TO
FAIL PARKING FAMILIES TO LOSE
ACCESS TO WATER. AND THE STATE
INEFFICIENTLY EXPEND PUBLIC
FUNDS TO DELIVER BOTTLED WATER.
INSTEAD THE STATE'S WORK
PRACTICALLY ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITIES TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS FOR WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE AT RISK AND ON
THE CUSP OF FAILURE. I THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING. WITH US AND
WE ARE NOT ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF NORMA FOR MISS
PLAYING. BUSINESS AREA CLARA
THANK. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER QUERY AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION OUR ORGANIZATION
IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF SB FOUR
OH THREE AND I'M ALSO SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER
CENTER ALSO COOK HAS SPONSORED
ITSELF AS MICHAEL MENTIONED
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. OF
CALIFORNIA TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
COMMUTING WATER SYSTEMS YOUR
FEWER THAN A THOUSAND RESIDENTS
AT ANY GIVEN TIME ROUGHLY ONE
IN SEVEN OF THE SECOND CALPERS
BY TAKING WATER AND WE NOW KNOW
THAT ABOUT ONE IN THREE ARE AT
RISK OF FAILURE. EVERYTHING
SOMETHING TO REMEMBER IS THAT
WHEN A COMMUNITY LOSE ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER IT DOESN'T
JUST IMPACT THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THAT CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IT ALSO CREATES THIS
LINGERING TRUST ISSUE SO EVEN
WHEN YOU GET. THAT WATER BACK
EVEN. AFTER THAT ACCESS IS
RETURNED. MANY COMMUNITY CAN TO
RELY BOTTLED INTENDED. BECAUSE
THEY JUST DON'T TRUST THAT
THEIR WATER IS SAFE AND THAT
IMPOSES A FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IT'S JUST
A GENERAL. IT LINGERING ISSUE
OF COST FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE ALTOGETHER. NOW
THE STATE BOARD STICKING WATER
NEEDS ASSESSMENT REFERENCE BY
MICHAEL IN THE SENATOR HAS
CREATED A TOOL TO MEASURE AND
MONITOR THE STATE ABILITY OF
OUR PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. AND
THAT TOOL SHOWS THAT FIFTY SIX
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVE AT LEAST ONE
WATER SYSTEM CLASSIFIED IT AS-
WELL. THAT MEANS THAT ANYONE OF
YOU MAY RECEIVE A CALL FROM A
CONSTITUENT THIS WEEKEND ABOUT
A SYSTEM IN YOUR DISTRICT IT IS
NO LONGER ABLE TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER. NO HE HAVE
ADMITTED TO FIX THE PORTABLE
DRINKING WATERFUND THE STATE
NOW HAS AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE THAT SHOULD ALLOW THEM.
TO PLAN FOR ATTRACTIVELY
INTERESTED STATE DRINKING WATER
CHALLENGES BUT FUNDING IS
UNLIMITED AND THE MORE WE HAVE
TO SPENT ON UNPLANNED
EMERGENCIES SELECT WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES. SO WE THINK SB FOUR
OH THREE AT THE COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT PROVIDES ONE MORE
TOOL TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH. MOTIONS
WITH. MOTION MARLBORO HARPER
BROUGHT IN A- DON'T THERE GUYS.
NONE OF THE STUFF. THE FILM LU
RIVAS IS THE SECOND. OKAY LET'S
SEE HERE- I'M LOOKING FOR WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION I BELIEVE I
HAVE CINDY TUCK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND ANTHONY TEN DON'T
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OPERATOR-
THANK YOU YOUR REQUIRE CURRY
AND MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL I DO HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION DID SENATOR GONZALEZ
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
YES OKAY SO- KNOWING THAT I
JUST WANT TO- THANKS AMERICANS
SALAS AND HER STAFF IN
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
RAISED AND- THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE SOONER GONZALEZ HAS
ACCEPTED A VERY POSITIVE AND I
WILL TAKE THE BILL BACK TO OUR
STATE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE TO
RECONSIDER THE POSITION AND
THAT WILL HAPPEN ON JULY JULY
NINTH SO THANKS AGAIN TO
SENATOR GONZALEZ IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MISS TAX-
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANTHONY
TENNANT TENNANT CHILL TELLING
HILLS BECAUSE OF. CANADA. GOOD
EVENING I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS HAMPTON WE
CANNOT KNOW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND WE REMAIN RESPECTFULLY ARE
OPPOSED- MUCH AMENDED THAT BUT
LET ME JUST START BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS- THROUGH THEIR
OPEN DOOR POLICY DURING THE
PAST OUR DELIBERATION AND
ALWAYS CONSIDER AND ARGUE
POINTS. WHILE WE APPLAUD THE
INTENT OF THE MEASURE AND OF
COURSE SHARE THE GOAL OF
RELIABLE SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THIS
MEASURE ISSUE FOR THREE HAS
SOME DEFICIENCIES THAT WE LIKE
TO SEE ADDRESSED THE OUR
MEMBERS SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
PUBLIC AGENCIES WITH ELECTED
BOARDS AND ALL SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT OFFER WATER YOU
FALL UNDER THE CATEGORY OF
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM NOT ALL
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS ARE IN
FACT SPECIAL DISTRICTS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE CREATED BY THE
VOTER AND ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BY THE VOTER. THEY'RE LIKE TO
BOARD MEMBERS LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY BATES TRANQUIL WATER
AND PAY THE SAME RATES AS THE
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY CERTAINLY
WANT SAFE RELIABLE AFFORDABLE.
DRINKING WATER SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY. SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ARE SUBJECT TO THE ACCOUNT.
THAT WE HAVE COME TO EXPECT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WEATHER'S
BROWN ACT- PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
RATEPAYER PROTECTIONS
TRANSPARENCY. UNFORTUNATELY
THIS MEASURE TREATS THE LOCAL
ELECTED AGENCIES THE SAME AS A
PRIVATE SYSTEM OR EVEN A FOR
PROFIT YSTEM. AND WHILE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AT RISK OF
WATER SYSTEMS ARE NOT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. NOT PUBLIC AGENCIES
COLLECTED BOARDS ARE NOT
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
EVEN ACCORDING TO THE STATE
WATER BOARDS RECENT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. OUR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS REPRESENT- WE THINK
THIRTY NINE OUT OF THE SIX
HUNDRED- TWENTY ASH AT RISK
SYSTEMS. AND OUR MEMBERS
EXPERIENCE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ARE OFTEN THE AGENCY HELPING TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF THE
NEIGHBORING WATER SYSTEM. IT'S
APPROPRIATE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE OUR NUMBER STAND
READY TO CONTINUE THAT WORK.
HOWEVER WHAT WE OPPOSE IS
INCREASING THE AUTHORITY OF AND
I'M ELECTED STATE BOARD TO
OVERRULE A LOCAL ELECTION. I
LIKE TO BOARD AND POTENTIALLY
GIVE A COMMAND COMMUNITIES
PUBLICLY ON ASSET. TO A PRIVATE
ENTITY AND THE MEASURE DOES NOT
HAVE THE RECOURSE FOR LOCAL
BOARD VOTERS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SAY. IN THE CASE OF PUBLIC
AGENCIES WITH ELECTED BOARDS
THERE IS A DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
THAT ALREADY EXISTED ACCORDING
TO MAPS HERTZBERG ACT. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH PUBLIC
AGENCIES IN A WAY THAT. GETS ON
THE RIGHT TO WATER. AND
RESPECTS THE RIGHTS OF LOCAL
BOARDERS MOTORISTS- WE HAVE
OFFERED SOME AMENDMENTS AND WE
FOUND WOULD HELP PROTECT THESE
DEMOCRATIC RIGHTS. ARMENIAN
SECOND A LITTLE MORE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO ANY IDEAS
THAT WOULD AFFECT THE SAME GOAL
SO I'LL CLOSE WITH. WITH
BACKPACKS THE STATE TO HELP
ASSESS SEVEN POWER I WOULD
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE TO MAINTAIN OWNERSHIP
AND GOVERNANCE OVER THEIR WATER
SYSTEM AND WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL- ON THIS
MEASURE AND BEYOND- AND I'M
GETTING IT RIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WILL
GO TO THE PUBLIC IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUDITORIUM. SEEING THE- IN-
WITNESSES OF IN THE TESTIMONY.
HEARING OPERATOR WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB. FOUR ZERO THREE.
AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE SIX
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH LINE SEVEN
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SEVEN FIFTY HERE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS MAYBE IT'S BETTER.
MOVIELINE SIX TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE CAN PICK UP THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OAK STREET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOTOR AMERICA CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIND SEVEN THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRISTINA PLEASE SHARE WITH THE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SIX THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU JOHN
MEMBERS WE INSTALL THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
STRONG OR THANK YOU. THE TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
AUDIENCE IN THE AUDITORIUM FOR
OPPOSING THIS BILL EIGHT SB
FOUR ZERO THREE. THING NONE ARE
THERE ANY IN THE REST REMOTE
TESTIMONY ROOM. HEARING NONE
OPERATORS ARE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR SB
FOUR ZERO THREE WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE OF OUR AGENDA THIS
EVENING. ENTER IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. MAN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. YEAH WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIX SIX SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DAVID WHEATLEY AS AN
INDIVIDUAL- IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS UNTIL DEVELOPERS OF
DENSITY BONUS UNTIL SHE HAVE TO
DO THEIR PART TO PROVIDE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER THANK YOU.
REMINDER THIS IS SP. FOUR ZERO
THREE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OTHERTHING NINE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. HOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST- WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH AQUA WE'VE
GOT ABOUT 99% OF THEIR
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND
BEEN SATISFIED IN TELESCOPES A
KEEP OFFICE- STEP AS A
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE GLAD TO
HAVE THIS COALITION OF NEW
SUPPORTERS AND WITH THAT I READ
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY LOOK-
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
AS WE ENTER ANOTHER DROUGHT- IT
WILL BE CRUCIAL FOR BOTH THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
AGAIN I REALLY WANT TO THE
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WITH
THOSE I WAS TO BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THIS EVENING THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND WE ARE CLOSED BY. I'M LUCKY.
LACKEY EVEN THOUGH BLOW. LITTLE
I AM ABOUT I'M ALMOST HI I'M
USUALLY WAS BECAUSE I REMEMBER
RIVAS FIVE OVER THE SIDE
WITHOUT MOVED WITHOUT A NOTE.
SIX TWO YOUR BILL THAT'S
FIFTEEN THANK YOU MUCH. WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE AGAIN FOR THOSE
THAT ARE LISTENING IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB TEN. AGAIN SB
TEN THE SENATOR WIENER- WE WILL
HAVE. THE FOLLOWING WHAT DO
THIS BILL FIRST SB TEN. AND YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY- FOR EVERYONE- I FIRST OFF
I WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY AND THOROUGHLY WITH
US- AND- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING OUR AUTHOR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS AND FOR BEING FLEXIBLE
IN WORKING WITH US AND- WE
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
PASSED THE BILL WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS SO AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH US.
HAPPY TO ADOPT THESE
AMENDMENTS- SO BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS- IT SHOULD BE FAMILIAR
BECAUSE IT WAS IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND PASSED OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR- AND
I'LL NOT ON THE EXACT IDENTICAL
FORM BUT IN A VERY SIMILAR
FORMS SB NINE OH TWO I'M SB TEN
I JUST TO BE CLEAR- BECAUSE
SOMETIMES A LOT OF THINGS
SPREAD AROUND ABOUT BILLS SB
TEN IS A COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY
BILL FOR CITIES CITIES DO NOT
HAVE TO UTILIZE THIS TOOL THE
CITY CAN DO NOTHING AND IGNORE
SB TIME. AND SB. TEN WILL HAVE
NO IMPACT ON THAT CITY- WE
CREATED SB TIME- BECAUSE WHAT
WE HEARD FROM CITIES OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. IS HEY WE KNOW
SOMETIMES YOU'RE REQUIRING US
TO DO THINGS- CAN YOU PLEASE
ALSO OR INSTEAD. GIVE US TOOLS
TO DO THINGS MORE EFFICIENTLY-
AND IN PARTICULAR IN A
STREAMLINED WAY. WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM CITIES IS YOU'RE
ALWAYS TELLING US. TO ZONE FOR
MORE HOUSING YOU'RE SORT OF YOU
KNOW. THE SAYING THAT THIS IS
WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO IS OWN
FROM OUR HOUSING ALLOW MORE
HOUSING. BUT THEN YOU YOU STATE
MAKE IT REALLY HARD FOR US. AND
LONG AND EXPENSIVE. AND
UNPREDICTABLE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
PHYSICAL PROCESS IN ORDER TO DO
THAT REZONING. AND SO I TOOK
THAT TO HEART. AND THAT'S WHEN
WE INTRODUCED THE PRECURSOR TO
SB TIME LAST YEAR'S HAS BEEN
ADDED TO. AND GIVE CITIES A
POWERFUL NEW TOOL THAT THEY CAN
USE OR NOT USE- SO THAT IF THE
CITY DECIDES. TO REZONE FOR
SMALL MULTI UNIT HOUSING. IN
ONE PART OF IT CITY ON ONE
BLOCK OF ITS CITY ON ONE PARCEL
IN ITS ENTIRE CITY WHATEVER
THEY WANT- SOMEWHERE UP TO TEN
UNITS. THE CITY AS LONG AS IT'S
IN A NON SPRAWL AREA INFILL.
WORK NEAR TRANSIT THE CITY CAN
DO THAT IN AN EXPEDITED
STREAMLINED WHY. THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED. TO MAKE CITIES LIVES
EASIER. IN DOING THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ASKING CITIES
TO DO. HIS OWN FOR MORE HOUSING
TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S PROFOUND-
HOUSING NEEDS- THIS BILL
APPLIES LIKE I SAID AN INFILL
AND TRANSIT RICH AREAS- IT
WILL- THE- FIFTH- AND THE BAY-
IT IS EXEMPTED OUT OF CERTAIN
WILD FIRE AREAS- IN ADDITION.
EXCUSE ME- SHOULD CAUSE SOME
WATER BEFORE I CAME UP HERE-
THE- IN ADDITION WE MADE SOME
AMENDMENTS- TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT OPEN SPACE BALLOT
MEASURES WE REMOVE THAT FROM
THE BILL ENTIRELY- SO THAT A
CITY COUNCIL CAN NOT. IN ANY
WAY OVERRIDE ANY KIND OF OPEN
SPACE GREEN BELT- PARKING RACK
KIND OF PROTECTIVE BALLOT
MEASURE THOSE PROBABLY WOULDN'T
QUALIFY IN THE BILL ANYWAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT INFILL SO
WE WERE VERY SENSITIVE THAT AND
WE REMOVED THAT- FROM THE BILL
ENTIRELY- SO COLLEAGUES THIS IS
LIKE I SAID AS A TOOL FOR
CITIES THAT THEY CAN USE OR NOT
USE. TO MAKE THEIR LIVES
EASIER- AND TO DO WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ASKING THEM TO DO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR FOR AN AYE
VOTE- WITH ME TODAY TESTIFIED
OR RICARDO FLORES IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DIRECTOR OF WHISKEY
SAN FRANCISCO SAN DIEGO- AND
ZACHARY HILTON WHO'S A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER. FROM GILROY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WE'RE LOOKING FOR MR
FLORES AND MR HILTON. ON THE
LINE. THE. I PROTECT OUR
SPEAKERS ARE NOT GETTING
ANSWERS FROM THE OPERATOR BUT
THERE APPARENTLY. IN THE ETHER
SOMEWHERE OPERATOR. YEAH SO
THAT THOSE SPEAKERS OF DIALED
IN YET HEY MAYBE THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY CALLING IN. THE. WELL
LET'S GIVE ME A MINUTE AND SEE
IF WE CAN GET HIM ON THE LINE.
ZAKRI HELTON AS CONNECTED GREAT
MISTER HEALTH IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO VOTE AGAIN. THIS IS SURE
I'LL SPEAKING HELLO COMMITTEE
CHAIRED MEMBER STOP. ARE YOU
READY YES WE ARE. THANK YOU
HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS
DOCUMENT PUBLIC I AM NOT KILL
DURING PRESIDENT OF FURY
CALIFORNIA HOW THE ADVOCATE AND
A DIVERSITY COUNCIL MEMBER WE
ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
DREAM OF OWNING A HOME IS NOT A
REALISTIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYONE. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE DEVELOPMENT OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR ALL
INCOME LEVELS WHILE LOOKING
PEOPLE LOOKING TOWARDS CREATIVE
CRUISING BIKE AT THE TIME. HI
I'VE STRUGGLED WITH HOW THE IN
OTHER LITTLE FAMILY GROUP. AT
THE BAY AREA FIREFIGHTER A
LOOKING ABLE TO AFFORD A HOME
WHERE I WORK. I AM STILL
WORKING AS A FIREFIGHTER AND IF
YOU CAN SOMETIME BE IN HOUR AND
A HALF OR LONGER. OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
HOUSING AND LET ME TO BECOME. A
HOUSING ADVOCATE AND JOINED
OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE REGION
AND SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
NEXT MINUTES. IS GOING TO BE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
CREATIVITY ON HOW THE
PRODUCTION. AND THAT INCLUDES
ALL PROJECTS A BIG WORKS WE
CAN'T GROW IN A MAJORITY OF OUR
LAND IS GOING FOR SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
GO RIGHT. IT IS ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONING MEDIAN THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING DUPLEXES TRIPLEXES
IMPORT BOXES. CALIFORNIA HAS
DESCENDED INTO A SUFFOCATING
HOUSING CRISIS. CONTRIBUTING TO
MASS MIGRATION OUT OF STATE.
ROCKETING EVICTION RATE. RECORD
LEVEL THE CHRONICLE WITH MISS
AND A GROWING CLASS OF LOWER
INCOME COMMUTERS UNABLE TO.
**** HELLO. MISTER HELPING OUT
THERE IS A SINGLE WORLD REQUIRE
A LEGISLATIVE BODY PASSED AN
ORDINANCE TO ADOPT THE PLAN AND
AN EXEMPTIVE DON'T NEED ACTION
FROM BEING CONSIDERED A PROJECT
IN YOUR SEQUEL. I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT AT THE TIME WHAT DOES
NOT SEEM GLOBAL HIGH MOMENTS
THAT BOX OBJECTIVE DESIGN
STANDARDS HISTORIC STANDARDS IN
MOST INSTRUCTION SB CAN CREATE
THE POPULARITY MODERATE DENSITY
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE RESERVE SIGNIFICANT
LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND MAKE THAT
FAST FASTER LESS EXPENSIVE AND
LESS RICH DIVERSITY TO
UNDERTAKING YOU PROGRESS TO
INCREASE DENSITY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS WE KIND OF AN
EFFECTIVE STEP FORWARD THINKING
WOULD HAVE BEEN A HISTORIC
PROBLEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU ANY CONCLUSION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HELTON AND NOW
WE'RE FOR A FOR AND YOU GOT ON.
OPERATOR YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS. MY NAME IS
RICARDO FLORES I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOCAL
INITIATIVES SUPPORT CORPORATION
IN SAN DIEGO AUTONOMOUS LET'S
COMPARE DIEGO. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT SIX AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING IT
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE WHAT
TAKING MEANINGFUL ACTION TO
REPLACE SEGREGATED LIVING
PATTERNS WITH TRULY INTEGRATED
AND BALANCED LIVING PATTERN. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
RELEASED A PROGRESS REPORT
ANALYZING PROGRESS MADE UNDER
SB THREE SEVEN FIVE THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY AND
CLIMATE PROTECTION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. THE REPORT
STATED THAT QUOTE CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT ACHIEVE THE NECESSARY
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION. MANDATES PART TWENTY
THIRTY AND BEYOND WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES HOW
COMMUNITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS ARE PLANNED FUNDED AND
BUILT. THE REPORT FURTHER
IDENTIFIED THE NEED TO INCREASE
HOME IN HIGH OPPORTUNITY AREAS
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. TO
DATE THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
NEITHER SB TEN WILL DO BOTH. AT
LAWMAKERS YOU CAN NO LONGER
TURN A BLIND EYE TO THE LEGAL
APARTHEID THAT IS IT IN THE
CITY YOU REPRESENTS. AN
APARTHEID THAT LOWERED LIFE
EXPECTANCY EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT HEALTH OUTCOMES
EARNING POTENTIAL AND EXPOSURE
TO ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE.
WITH ONE VOTE ONE VOTE YOU CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR BROWN
BLACK AND POOR CONSTITUENT. I
URGE THE DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO LIVE YOUR VALUES AND
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE WORLD AS A MODEL OF
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY ROOTED IN
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND SHOW THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE PRESENTS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
FUTURE OF HUMANITY. AND I URGE
THE REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO LIVE YOUR VALUES ARE
REJECTING GOVERNMENT
RESTRICTIONS ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY AND A PART OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES OF WHICH ARE
HEALTH AND ECONOMY DEPENDS.
VOTE YES ON SB TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE ARE NOW
LOOKING FOR THE WITNESSES SINCE
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO MISTER
BRANDON- MAYOR CITY OF REDONDO
BEACH. AND JASMINE JOHNSON IS
TIONS FOR SOCIAL. OF LAW
ANGELES OPERATOR MISTER BRANDT
OR MISTER. BOB GOOD EVENING
CARE AND YEAR CURRYING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BILL GRAN MAYOR REDONDO BEACH I
SPOKE TO YOU LAST YEAR WHEN
THIS BILL WITH SB NINE OH TWO.
THERE WE ARE AGAIN IS SB CAN
VIRTUALLY THE SAME BILL WITH
SOME SMALL TWEAKS MOST
CONCERNING ABOUT SB TENNIS
SECTION ONE BEGIN AT ANY CITY
OR COUNTY IN THE STATE. WE WILL
TAKE IN OVER RIGHT AWAY. IN
THIS. REPORT MAJORITY VOTE OF
THE COUNCIL YOU CAN'T OVER RIDE
VOTER APPROVED INITIATIVE BY A
THREE FIFTHS VOTE OF THE CITY
COUNCIL ANY MORE THAN YOU COULD
OVERRIDE IT WITH UNANIMOUS
VOTE. THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE INITIATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW VOTERS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
LAWS DIRECTLY. ARTICLE TWO OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
SIMPLY STATES INITIATIVE AND
REFERENDUM POWERS MAY BE
EXERCISED BY THE ELECTORS OF
EACH CITY OR COUNTY. YOU CAN'T
UNDO THESE POWERS RESERVED IN
CONSTITUTION WITH LEGISLATION
IT REQUIRES A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
VOTE 2% WE MAY NOT LIKE IT
BEING LEGISLATORS OURSELVES BUT
THIS FORM OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY
HAS BEEN RESERVED OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS. SURE THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
BILLS OF THE SPEAKER I NEED A
COUNCIL NEED DO NOTHING BUT Y.
MISLEAD THEM INTO THINKING THEY
CAN VIOLATE THE STATE
CONSTITUTION IS S. B. TENCENT
YES. AND WHY ALLOW THEM TO
CIRCUMVENT PROPER ENVIRONMENT
ONE HOUSES WHEN THIS BILL COULD
ALLOW THE ADDITION OF THOUSANDS
OF RESIDENTIAL UNITS TO A CITY
OR COUNTY. A KEY COMPONENT
MISSING IN SB TENDED ANY
REFERENCE TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THIS IS NOTHING BUT A MARKET
RATE HOUSING BILLS THE IDEA
THAT ADDING MORE MARKET RATE
HOUSING WILL TRICKLE DOWN TO
AFFORDABLE UNITS S.
SPECULATIVE ANY DUBIOUS
CONCLUSION. MANDATE 30% OF THIS
PROJECT THE LOW INCOME HE WILL
BE ADDRESSING THE REAL PROBLEMS
HAVE A CALIFORNIA. SENATOR
WIENER PULLED THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SECTION FROM
SB NINE OH TWO LAST YEAR. YOU
SHOULD PULL IT AGAIN FROM S. B.
TEN THIS YEAR. AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT ASKRI NO VOTE ON SB TEN
FOCUS MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND NOT MARKET RATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BRANDT- NOW
WE'RE LOOKING FOR JASMINE
JOHNSON PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ADVANCEMENT I'M WITH
BUSINESS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LA AND THE
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH OF THE
FLIGHT. FILE ITEMS THEY ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB TEN WELL
WE APPRECIATE OFFICE ANCHOR
DRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS
EVERYTHING GREATLY UNDERMINES
DEMOCRATIC PROPERTIES AND BROWN
THE LOBBY PROTECTION. AS WE CAN
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OVER A
DOCTOR LOCAL INITIATIVE TO
BRING THE POWER RESIDENTS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THE FIVE
HOW THEIR TEAMS THEIR SHAPE.
NUMBER WOULD BRING CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
INITIATIVES SUCH AS LOCAL
EFFORTS TO CREATE THAT BACKING
PLATE OIL GRAYSON HOMES. AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INITIATIVES
SUCH AS INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
AND RENT CONTROL OKAY LIBATION
MEASURES FURTHERMORE IT IS
PERMITTED AEROBICS BUT THEY'VE
ALL OF THE JEWS IT IS VERY TO
REDRESS THESE ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY I THINK THAT WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TURN
A BLIND EYE THE HOUSE ONLY
DECISIONS WOULD IMPACT
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND THE
VERY PEOPLE DISCORDANT
DIFFICULT THE BENEFIT. THIS IS
TROUBLING GIVEN THAT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS CAN OFTEN NOT THAT%
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
AND PUBLIC PRACTICE EVEN INTO
THINGS BECAUSE I'M XIN. AND
THIS IS ESPECIALLY VERY
CONCERNED TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THE EXPERIENCE A LEGACY OF
INDUSTRIAL CONTAMINATION BUT
THE SOUTH CENTRAL LA OVER
CURRENTLY OPPOSING A MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT. THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED IN A BROWNSTONE. AND
APPLIED FOR INFILL EXEMPTION.
WHAT'S MORE AT THIRTY WILL
ALLOW GRAB. CONCERNED MAKING
AREA. INTO RESIDENTIAL WHAT I
FULLY A- AND- THE- HEALTH OF
LOS AND BUILDING HOUSING. ON
POTENTIALLY POLLUTED AIR.
BETWEEN LOCAL COMMERCE OR LIGHT
NATIONALLY. THAT PRODUCE AIR
POLLUTION POCKET. TO THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE. AND MITIGATE
DURING AND- REVIEW PROCESS
UNDERSTANDABLE. BLACK AT I
WORKED AGAINST THE PAPER BILL
TO ACHIEVE AND HOW AND CRIME IN
BOTH. THE BILL VEERAPPA. ARE
BASED ON VAGUELY DEFINED
MEASURES OF JOB RICH AND
TRANSMISSION TRANSLITERATION
WHICH COULD INADVERTENTLY LEAD
TO INCREASE YOU. MISSION
FURTHERMORE THERE NO CORONARY
AFFORDABILITY OR VALUE CAPTURE
MEASURES BUILT INTO THE BILL
WHAT SETS IT UP THE ONLY
EXACERBATE THE CURRENT HOUSING
PRACTICE. 23-14 RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AT THE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE ARE NOW
LOOKING FOR IN THE AUDIENCE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB. TEN
ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B. TEN- WE
HAVE ONE- GENTLEMAN IN THE
OTHER. WELCOME I'M TERM MEMBERS
ALEX TAURUS WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS VOLUNTARY YET
IMPACTFUL TOOL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY-
OTHER MEMBERS AS ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY. FOR S. B. TEN
IN SUPPORT. HEARING NONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR OR LOOKING FOR THE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. SB. TEN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AND SURE THIS TIME WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT AND WE HAVE BEEN FIFTEEN
MINUTES THAT WE WILL DO BE
DOING OF THE SUPPORT. ON S. B.
TEN. AND THEN WE WILL THEN WE
WILL MOVE INTO THE OPPOSITION
BUT FIRST WE ARE DOING S. B.
TEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
START WITH THE LINE SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING SICKENING FAN ON BEHALF
OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE SIX FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BEING
RAFEAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
AND THANK YOU SENATOR WE ARE
FOR YOUR DOCUMENTS AND ADDRESS
IN CALIFORNIA HI AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS THANK YOU. THIS
IS A REMINDER OF BLIND NAME.
YOUR POSITION OF THE BILL IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
NINE SIX TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT'S A NOT A NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS I WAS AFTER
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AREA
COUNCIL AND CALIFORNIA YIMBY- A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINE
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER STACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS PLEASED
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. FIND SIX ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO THE- FOR
OUR IN BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ADAM BOOKBINDER YOU
DISTRICT TWENTY EIGHT CITIES
CAMPBELL ON BEHALF THAT THEY IN
BE IN SUPPORT. NINE SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GETTING ENSURING MEMBERS WE SAW
BEHALF. PLEASE DO NOT CONTINUE
NEAR LONDON. THREE FOUR EIGHT.
NINE SEVEN SEVENTY ONE THESE
GOOD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS JUST
MY WRITTEN BOOK ABOUT A
LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB TEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MORE NINE SIX FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
HENRY HOOKER ON BEHALF OF SANTA
CRUZ MD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SIX FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVEN CARE
MEMBER IMPACT POINT THEY KIND
OF APPLE THE FALLING
ORGANIZATIONS THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TEN EAST BAY
UNITY ALAMEDA CRAPPIE WENT OVER
THE NEIGHBOR'S MOUNT UNION BE
THANKFUL FOR EVERYONE PEOPLE
FOR HOUSING WORKED COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY IN THE STREETS
FOR PEOPLE PAMPERED BERKELEY
AND BE URBAN. ENVIRONMENTAL IN
THE IN THE ACTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE NINE NINE.
GOOD EVENING ADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WARRANTY THE ONE HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD EVENING MADAM
FAIR NUMBERS GET A COPY OF
CRANES ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AND AT HOME IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX. YEAH I'D
LIKE TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT ARE
ON THE LINE YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONE LINE WHEN YOU
WERE NOT SPEAKING SO THAT WE
CAN HEAR THE SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
NINE SIX SIX THREE. THE LINE
SIX SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS HERIS ROSENBLOOM ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYTHING PARA MEMBERS JORDAN
GRINDS ON BEHALF OF AN INFILL
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY
TWENTY TWO AN EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND. SEVEN FIFTY
ONE. HI GOOD EVENING THIS IS
CAPITAL GAINS ON BEHALF OF AN
ANSWER FOR EVERYONE AND GIVE ME
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. AND. SEVEN
NINETEEN. THEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
FIFTY. ONE SEVEN FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH. MOVED TO LINE
SIX NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN CARE THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
FOR FIELD SEVEN COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK YOU.
FIND. SEVEN SEVENTY. HI THIS IS
CAROLINE WITH NINETY IN THE
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR AND WE
SUPPORT THE PIZZA. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN THIRTY. HI GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LESLIE VASQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN COURT. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO
MACGINNIS FROM VENTURA COUNTY
SB IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN TWELVE. HI ALISON
CHANDLER FROM LOS ANGELES
HOLLYWOOD FORWARD STORIES FROM
THE FRONT LINE UNITED WAY
EVERYONE IN AND STRONG SUPPORT
I'M ALSO A SINGLE FAMILY
HOMEOWNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY THANK YOU. AND. SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN- JOHN PEREZ FROM
NORWALK CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT. YES HI YES I'M
CALLING IN WE'RE REPRESENTING
THAT PARENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF US
SENATOR WE ARE BEING REMOVED
AND ARRESTED FOR BEING A PET A
FILE ON. PLEASE WHO IS- ONE
SEVEN SIXTY SIX. BOB MICHAELS
ACARI US IN CASTRO VALLEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TEN NINE
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE. MARKET YOUR-
GOOD EVENING CARE ACT SELLING
MEMBERS- MARKERS CITY BALLOT
MEDIA EIGHTY EIGHTEEN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
HENRY FONG RESIDENT- OFTEN JUST
COUNTY REPRESENTING- BUDGET
HELPING LA IN STRONG SUPPORTER
THAT THEY CAN THANK YOU. AND.
SEVEN SIXTY NINE. HI THIS IS
STEVE MARCEL I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHSIDE FORD AND-
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
KRISTEN JEFFREY I'M A SINGLE
FAMILY HOMEOWNER IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND A MOTHER OF
THREE AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL TEN AND- SENATE
EARLIER. AND. SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME ALL THE CORE
OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND ST PORT
AND THANKS. NINE SEVEN TWENTY
ONE. IN IN THE MEDICARE NUMBER
THAT COMMITTEE ADAMANTLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TRUMP THE COURT THANK
YOU. NINE SIX TWENTY ONE. HI
LISA NELSON REPRESENTING
RESIDENTS FOR DEVELOPER LAND
GRABS SUPPORTING SCOTT WIENER
SAID SB TEN. AT THE TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN OUR QUEUE.
PLEASE CONTINUE. WE WILL NOT
GOING TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THIS IS S. B.
TEN WE WOULDTAKE YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION- AGAIN THIS
IS S. B. TEN SO WE WILL START
WITH THE AUDITORIUM I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
AUDITORIUM. ANY WITNESSES AT
REMOTE TESTIMONY. HEARING NONE
WILL NOW LIVE HERE IN THE
OFFICE MOVE TO THE PHONES THANK
YOU. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION I WILL
REMIND THE AUDIENCE THAT ARE
CALLING IN THAT- JUST AS WE'VE
DONE WITH THE- THE- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT YOU GET FIFTEEN
MINUTES WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU DON'T DO NOT
GET THROUGH ON THE LINES YOU
CAN ALWAYS SEND THE LETTER INTO
OUR PORTAL THANK YOU. SO WOULD
LINE AT SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS MADE LETTING STAFF
AND SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS. IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN SIX
THREE. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY
THAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES COALITION AND
ACHIEVE POWER ALTHOUGH AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT. MARKS I
RESPECTFULLY HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP RESPECTFULLY POSING
LESS AMENDED TO PRESERVE THE
BENEFITS OF STREAMLINING FOR
EXISTING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNDER EXISTING ZONING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE THREE OH
NINE. I MEAN BILL CAN ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN FIFTY SIX. OKAY HEAR
ME. YES YES THREE CANARIA.
AVING CHAIR MEMBERS DAN
HATCHING- REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF FOSTER CITY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SEVEN FIVE
THREE. SEVEN KANDEL THE MERITS
OF THE CITY OF LAFAYETTE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LAFAYETTE
AND COLLEAGUES- NO CITY COUNCIL
SHOULD EVER OVERRIDE OF THE
COMMISSION IF THANKS AND PLEASE
ADEQUATE ABILITY YES I'M
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FIFTEEN
THE- NINE SEVEN EIGHTEEN
TRANSIT RICH- WHICH IS. GOOD
EVENING PARA MEMBERS PER FORTY
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND BEVERLY
HELP AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND SIX
NINETY SEVEN. HELLO HEATHER
KELLER RESIDENT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND MEMBER OF LIBERAL
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN THIRTY TWO. AND SEVEN
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOND
TO A LINE. SIX TWENTY TWO. SIX
ONE SIX TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING RECALL
MASON CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE MENTAL GIANT
JEFF THIS ALLIANCE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT SIERRA CLUB
ORGANIZING TO DEMAND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
RIGHT AND COMMUNITY FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. PINE SEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT. MANAGER MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AS DESCRIBED IN OUR LETTER TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I KNOW. SIX TWENTY. IT
EVENING ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER LONG POVERTY
RESPECTFULLY APPROACHED MY FOR
MONDAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR FORTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER SISTER SANDY
HUBBARD A TOWN HOMEOWNER
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY VILLAGE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS WORKABLE CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND
A. FIVE SIXTY SIX. RIGHT ON
OPPOSED THE PLAN THANK YOU.
LIKE TO REMIND WITNESSES IF YOU
COULD PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE
LINE WHEN YOU WERE NOT SPEAKING
THANK YOU. SOUTH LOS ANGELES
NUMBER OF CATHOLIC UNITED LABOR
GREAT BRITAIN AVENUE BLOCK CLUB
IN LEIMERT PARK WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. GEN THANK YOU.
NINE SIX SEVENTY THREE.
BROADGREEN BOTH LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
TEN THE BILL REQUIRES NO FORMAL
HOUSING INCREASES TRAFFIC.
DEVELOPERS. NINE SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE VICTORIA GOLD MOUNT SHASTA
REPRESENTING CITIZENS FOR
QUALITY GROWTH EARTH CLARA
GLOBAL TV WATER FLOWS FREE AND
MOUNT SHASTA TOMORROW IN
ADDITION A MEMBER OF THE VERBAL
CALIFORNIA UNAMBIGUOUSLY
PROFOUNDLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
WINDS FIVE NINETY EIGHT. GOOD
MY NAME IS HOLLY OSBORNE I AM A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS OF AB
SIXTY SIX AND A MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN ELEVEN.
LINDA SHOW ALL RESIDENTS LONG
BEACH CITY AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THANK YOU.
NINE SIX SEVENTY HI ANNIE GEGEN
HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN CORD TO
COMMUNITIES WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS LIBERAL CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT LOS ANGELES CHIEF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST VEHEMENT
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THANK YOU.
AND. SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES WE CAN AREA. I'M SORRY. YES
WE CAN AREA. YES I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF SCOTT WIENER
HOLDING ANOTHER. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE SEVEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU
YEAH. HI THIS IS BETH WALLACE
FROM MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION OF SILICON VALLEY
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE SB. TEN I AM
A SEVEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND. SEVEN FORTY FIVE.
MOVE ON TO LINE UP FIVE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA. MEMBER OF
SAVE LAFAYETTE LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA KELLY AND- UNITED
NEIGHBORS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
TEN ALONG WITH ANYTHING ELSE
THAT MR WEINER PUTS MORE WORK
THEY ARE NOT AFFORDABLE YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. HI MARY GALLAGHER FROM
PALO ALTO AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS MOVABLE CALIFORNIA
AGREE A 100% WITH THE TWO
SPEAKERS WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION AND THE KING COURAGE
A NO VOTE ON THE PLAN IS FLAWED%
I JUST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE THREE SEVEN
ONE. THIS IS RECALL WITH
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE SB
TEN STRONGLY THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
CATHERINE DREYFUS FROM SANTA
MONICA GROUP IS LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M SEVEN
TWENTY TWO. GENERAL DINE'S
REPRESENTING THE MIRACLE MILE
PRESIDENTIAL ASSOCIATION OF LOS
ANGELES AN AFFILIATED THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS ANOTHER BUBBLE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX FORTY SEVEN. ELIZABETH
CLAIRE SANTA MONICA LOMA
NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE THOUSAND
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TEN THANK
YOU. NINE SIX NINETY NINE. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS STANDING
CHAPLAIN I WILL BE SENDING A
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
SACRAMENTO VALLEY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB CARES AT THE DENTAL
PLAN WILL HELP YOU THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN NINETY. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER HOLDEN OF THE
MANGAN PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ALSO A MEMBER OF
LITTLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN. THANK
YOU. FINEST SIX FIFTY EIGHT.
YES CAPPING NIGHT WITH A FRIEND
OF SUNSET PARK IN SANTA MONICA
AND- WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE- SB
TEN THERE'S NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND REQUIRES. NINE
SEVEN SEVENTEEN. CHANNEL LEVINE
WESTWOOD HIGHLANDS
APPROPRIATIONS SAN FRANCISCO
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO CREATING
TINY HOMES FOR FAMILY IT WILL
NOT. AND SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS IS MATTHEW
BAKER WITH PLANNING
CONSERVATION WEEK RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE MUST AMENDED FOR THE
RECENT ARTICULATED THE PRIMARY
TESTIMONY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. SIX OH NINE. ON THE
CUANDO LOS ANGELES PROGRESSIVE
ASIAN NETWORK FOR ACTION AND
SAVE OUR SENIORS STRONGLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. NO FIVE FIVE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MERRY SHOP KORAN
SECRETARY FOR BOTH PROTECTS
GAMBINO COUNTY AND PROTECT
MONTEREY COUNTY WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS UNDEMOCRATIC
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
FIFTY. JACKSON HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT THIS HAS NORTH
PORTABLE HOUSING OPPOSE THANK
YOU. NINE SIX SEVENTY FIVE. HI
MY NAME IS MARCY GIVES YOU
GATHER MOST OF THAT SOUTH BAY
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ONE
SECOND- YOU DON'T OF EACH DAY
YOUR BRAND AS WELL AS THE
SECOND THE SPEAKER WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED DISAPPEAR.
THANK YOU. FOR NINE SIX
SIXTEEN. HELLO YES HI MY NAME
IS. I DON'T KNOW. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE HAVE ONE MINUTE
LEFT FOR CALLS IN FOR
OPPOSITION ONE MINUTE LEFT.
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY WHAT A
LINE. SEVEN NINETY ONE. HI THIS
IS SUSAN KIRSCH CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CATALYST FOR LOCAL
CONTROL STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
SENATE BILL TEN THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN NINETY TWO. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS TRYING TO GOT TO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS STATED
IN OUR LETTER IS COMMUNICATED
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
SEVEN NINETY THREE THIS WILL BE
THE LAST CALL. FRAZIER CRANE
SHARE OF NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS
TOGETHER WHICH SANTA MONICA
CITY COUNCIL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS DETERMINED
TO STOP AS HE CAN. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WANT TO FIRST THANK
ALL THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF THE BECAUSE
OF THE TESTIMONY THIS EVENING I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REMEMBER IT
REMINDED THOSE OF YOU THAT WERE
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH THAT YOU
CAN- PUT INFORMATION INTO OUR
PORTAL. AND YOU CAN SEE THAT I
BELIEVE ONLINE SO WE HAVE A
WRITTEN TESTIMONY CAN COME
THROUGH A POSITION PORTAL ON A
COMMITTEE AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. OKAY SO-
WILL MOVE TO QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKING. YEAH I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY- APOLOGIZING FOR THE
DURATION OF. DISRESPECTING
SUPPRESSION BY A NUMBER OF THE
COLLAR'S NOT WAS INEXCUSABLE NO
MATTER WHAT THEIR POSITION HAS-
BUT AS I MOVE ON THE LANGUAGE
ALLOWING THIS BILL TO AUTHORIZE
THE CITY COUNCIL TO OVERTURN
VOTER APPROVAL ORDINANCES SEEMS
TO BE A BIG OBSTACLE AND I KNOW
YOU DRESSED TO LAST TIME- ARE
YOU UNWILLING TO ADDRESS THAT.
THROUGH THE AMENDMENT PROCESS
SERVER HOW HOW. HOW FOR MORE
YOU ON THAT ISSUE SURE AND IF I
GET THE SIX CERTIFIED PREACHER
THAT I REMEMBER OUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE LAST
YEAR. SO LAST THE WHAT WE DID
THIS YEAR. IS WE MADE IT.
INSTEAD OF REMOVING WE MET
DRAMATICALLY NARROWER- AND- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE ARE SOME CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS A- SMALL
NUMBER- THAT BUT BUT- IT COULD
GROW- THAT HAVE MADE IT
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE. FOR
CITY COUNCIL EVEN TO ADOPT THE
HOUSING ELEMENT BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE THAT THE ONLY WAY. YOU
CAN EVEN MOVE A COMMA IN TERMS
OF THE ZONING CODE THE PLAN
CODE. IS TO GO TO THE VOTERS-
AND SO WE HAVE CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
LITERALLY INCAPACITATED FROM
ADOPTING EVEN HOUSING ELEMENT
AND DOING ANY ZONING WORK
WHATSOEVER- AND SO. WHAT WE DID
WAS WE BASICALLY NARROWED IT
DOWN TO THAT VERY NARROW
SUBCLASS GETTING RID OF THE- IT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. BALLOT
MEASURES THAT RESTRICT
DEVELOPMENT OVERWHELMINGLY THEY
ARE OPEN SPACE PROTECTION GREEN
BELT THOSE KINDS OF PROMISES
THAT WERE ALL FAMILIAR WITH AND
WE SAW OVER THE STATE. WE
REMOVE THOSE FROM THE BILL
ENTIRELY AND THAT'S THE LARGE
MAJORITY OF THEM- AND SO WE
MADE A MUCH NARROWER TO FOCUS
ON THE VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT
HAS CREATED A PROBLEM A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITIES. WHERE THEY'RE
NOT EVEN ABLE TO COMPLY WITH
STATE HOUSING LAWS WE'VE HAD
ALSO INCREASED THE THRESHOLD
EVEN FOR THAT NARROW BANDS.
HAVING REMOVED THE LARGE
MAJORITY ENTIRELY FOR THAT ARE
BAD MAKING IT A TWO THIRDS VOTE
AND SEVEN MAJORITY VOTE WAS ON
MOST COUNCILS PICA BEFORE OUT
OF FIVE FOR THE- YOU KNOW I
THINK THE MOST COMMON FORM
COUNCIL- AND AS YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW. AS AS MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE SENATOR. WHO THE LOCAL
GUY YOUR THEM OVER MY HOUSING
BILLS SAID HE SAID IN THAT
NARROW THIS NARROW SUBSET. YOU
KNOW COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
ACCOUNTABLE. TO THEIR VOTERS I
KNOW WHEN I WAS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LAWS NUMBER
SUPERVISORS THERE WERE SOME
SITUATIONS. WHERE WE WERE ABLE
TO OVERRIDE OR CHANGE BALLOT
MEASURES- AND I DOUBT SOME OF
THAT I WAS TAKEN EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY FOR THE REASONS THAT
ALL OF US AROUND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. UNDERSTAND SO I
DON'T SEE THIS IS SOMETHING
WORK COUNCILS ARE GOING TO ****
NILLY. DO THAT BUT IN A WAY IT
IS A SAFETY VALVE. FOR THAT
VERY SMALL SUBSET OF CITIES
THAT HAVE THESE. BALLOT
MEASURES THAT MAKE IT REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO EVEN
COMPLY WITH THAT LAW SO WE
TRIED TO. IN SEVERAL LIMITING
IT SAYS REALLY NARROW AND-POCASSET AND MAKE A RAZOR SHARP
SO THAT'S WHAT I EXPLANATION OF
HOW WE- GOT HERE. IS THAT A
CONTINUING CONVERSATION OF
COURSE- AND I UNDERSTAND THE
YOU KNOW THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER BUT WE TRIED TO
THREAD THAT NEEDLE. WELL I DO
AGREE WITH THE- SENATOR GLAZERS
ASSESSMENT HAVING SERVED ON THE
CITY COUNCIL FOR NINE YEARS AND
IF YOU OVERTURN. THEIR WILL I
THINK- YOU COULD SAY
POTENTIALLY ADIOS TO THAT. THAT
SPOT. SO THAT BEING SID- UP TO
GIVE HIS SOME SO HAVE YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT TO APPRECIATE
THAT EXPLANATION I APPRECIATE
THAT. NUMBER OKAY I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- YOU KNOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- I KNOW WE'VE HAD
SOME DISCUSSIONS ON THIS BILL-
AND YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS HAS RAISED
SEVERAL CONCERNS THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS HAVE ALSO BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION- AND I KNOW
I'VE DISCUSSED THESE WITH YOU
AND YOUR PREVIOUS ITERATION. OF
THIS BILL YOU KNOW THE ANALYSIS
STATES THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS
LOCAL AGENCIES TO REZONE AND
UPS OWN CERTAIN PARCELS. WITH
IT ALL UP. TO A DENSITY OF TEN
UNITS PER PARCEL WITHOUT
CONDUCTING A SEQUEL REVIEW IN A
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT- IS
A DESIGNATED VERY HIGH FIRE.
HAZARD ZONE AND IT IS ALSO IN.
HE NOT TRANSIT READ CHEN IT'S
AN URBAN AREA- I KNOW IN IN THE
ANALYSIS IT DID SAY THAT THESE
ZONES TEND TO BE MORE RURAL AND
THAT'S NOT THE CASE. IN MY
DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES- AND SO
I WANTED TO NOTE THIS THAT THIS
ISN'T THE CASE LIKE I SAID IN
MY DISTRICT AND- I WOULD. JUST
DEFINITELY LIKE TO SEE YOU
CLARIFY THIS PROVISION. AT
THEIR CLIENT YES GO AHEAD NO
THANK YOU FOR THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I KNOW SOMEONE
MEMBER BLOOM AND I'VE ALSO HAD
DISCUSSIONS. ABOUT THIS AND SO
THE ANSWER RIGHT NOW THE VERY
HIGH- WILDFIRE SEVERITIES OWNER
I ALWAYS MESS UP THAT- THE NAME
OF THE VERY HIGH RISK AREAS.
THOSE MAPS- ARE EXEMPT FROM THE
BILL- BUT THEN THERE IS AN
EXCEPTION TO THAT EXEMPTION
THAT'S REPRESENTS- THAT IF A
CITY. AND ITS FIRE MARSHAL HAVE
BASICALLY DETERMINED THAT A
PARTICULAR AREA HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVELY MADE SAFER RIGHT
YOU'D BE IT'S ON A VERY HIGH
RISK MAP. BUT THIS AREA HAS
BEEN A LOT OF WORK DONE YOU
KNOW TO ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
FIRE OFFICIALS DUE TO MAKE A
NEIGHBORHOOD OR BLOCK- SAFER SO
THAT IT'S EFFECTIVELY THAT AREA
IS NO LONGER. AT THAT SAME
LEVEL OF RISK AND THAT WOULD BE
OKAY AND THAT WOULD BE A LOCAL
DECISION. YOU KNOW IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE LOCAL
FIRE MARSHAL IN USING ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA IT'S A CAL FIRE
STANDARDS IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
THAT HAS TO USE SO THAT'S-
THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS I KNOW-
THAT THERE ARE SOME OTHER
ISSUES IN THE SUMMER BLOOMING
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE WHOLE.
INGRESS AND EGRESS ISSUES IS ON
ONE WAY TO GET IN AND GET OUT
I'M VERY SENSITIVE THAT- AND
I'VE ACTUALLY COMMITTED TO SOME
MEMBER I'M SORRY TO SAY YOUR
NAME SO MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A FEW
TIMES- COMMITTEE WAS WELL. THAT
WE ARE THE TO WORK YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IF THE IF THE COMMITTEE
PASSES THE BILL OUT- BEFORE
COMES TO THE FLOOR- TO DO SOME
REFINEMENTS ARE. THIS LANGUAGES
EXCEPTION LANGUAGE WE DID NOT
CREATE A FOR THIS BILL. THIS
WAS THE IS ALIVE THE EXEMPTION
THAT'S IN SB THIRTY FIVE IT WAS
IN OTHER- BILLS THAT I THINK A
PASS TO THIS COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR MAYBE SB TWELVE I'M NOT
SURE WHICH. OFFICE THIS IS A
STANDARD. TEN LANGUAGE FURTHER
BURKE HIGH WHILE- IT. AND SOME
SAID. TO THE FACT THAT IT IS IN
A BUNCH OF. BILLS YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE. SO DIFFERENT. BUT
I'M VERY OPEN TO A CONVERSATION
TO ADDRESS REFINER- BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM. AND AS I'VE BEEN THE KIDS
YOU I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SITTING DOWN- PERHAPS WITH A
FEW MEMBERS. ARE TO TALK
THROUGH- THAT VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. OKAY THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT AND-
I WILL BE FOLLOWING UP AND I
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL. COMMIT TO THAT ABSOLUTELY
AND I KNOW YOU'RE- A GOOD
MEMBER THAT FOLLOWS THROUGH. ON
YOUR COMMITMENTS- AND- I MEAN
BECAUSE- OF THIS DOES REQUIRE A
CITY TO. PASS AN ORDINANCE IN
ORDER- TO USE THIS AS A TOOL-
FIFTY FOUR TODAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING. BUT YOU KNOW I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IF
WE HAVEN'T- YOU KNOW FAR
DISCUSSIONS- DON'T. RESULT IN A
CHANGE. THANK YOU SURE. THANK
YOU SOMEONE MEMBERS ONLY MEMBER
VOEPEL. SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL
NOW I DID NOT IN THE PAST I WAS
OUT OF THE GATE AGAINST IT FOR
ALL THE SAME REASONS THAT ALL
THE OPPOSITION HAVE. TESTIFIED
ON BUT- I FIND SENATOR WIENER
TO BE VERY- THOROUGH IN HIS
RESPONSES TO ME AND I
APPRECIATE THAT GREATLY HE IS
NOT A SILVER TONGUED DEVIL BUT
HE IS REASONABLE HE'S-
ANALYTICAL AND HE MAKES HIS
POINTS IN OUR COGNIZANT AND
PERFECT WAY SO. MY MAIN
OBJECTION ON THIS BILL WAS OF
COURSE THE OVERRIDING OF LOCAL.
PEOPLE I LIKE THE OFFICIALS SO.
MY THOUGHT PROCESS WHICH
SENATOR WIENER SPARKED OFF WAS
OKAY LET'S ASSUME A CITY
COUNCIL OVERRIDES ZONI IN
EXCEPT FOR A- IF THE VOTERS ARE
THAT ANGRY OKAY COME UP. IT'S
CALLED DEMOCRACY SO. THAT TAKES
CARE OF MY MAIN OBJECTION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I THANK
YOU SIR FOR WORKING WITH ME AD
NAUSEAM HE WORKED HARD THANK
YOU HELLO THANK YOU THE SUMMER
VOEPEL SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
AGREEING A LANGUAGE THAT
CLARIFIES THAT THE BILL DOES
NOT SUPERSEDE LOCAL BALLOT
MEASURES FOR. OPEN SPACE. ON
THAT SAID I STILL HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH THE
BILL THAT I'VE DISCUSSED WITH
THE- AUTHOR AND- I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT I SUPPORTED LAST
YEAR'S VERSION SB NINE OH TWO
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING AND
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR FOR
TWO IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS. ONE
OF THEM WAS THE OPEN SPACE
ISSUE ON THE OTHER I WAS THE
ONE THAT- MY- A COLLEAGUE GOT-
FROM LOS ANGELES- ARE BROUGHT
UP AND THAT'S THE EXEMPTION-
FOR A VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES AND TO- LAST YEAR I WAS
ABLE TO OBTAIN A COMMITMENT TO-
TO AMEND THE BILL- FOR A FULL
EXEMPTION. FOR VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES AND- THAT IS NOT
IN AND- THIS VERSION OF THE
BILL UNFORTUNATELY- LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
OR WITHIN THOSE FIRE SEVERITY
SOUNDS AGORA HILLS PACIFIC
PALISADES TO PAYING A CANYON IN
MALIBU TO NAME JUST A FEW OF
ALL OF THESE HAVE BURNED
HISTORICALLY AND IN RECENT
YEARS THEY ARE COVERED WITH
THOUSANDS OF HOMES WINDING
STREETS AND VERY LIMITED
INGRESS AND- EGRESS AND- OF
COURSE WE'RE SAYING. RECORD
SETTING HEAT WAVES NOW AND YEAR
AFTER YEAR OF- INTENSIFYING
WILDFIRE SEASONS. AND I BELIEVE
THE DENSIFIED PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE TO DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES JUST PUTS MORE PEOPLE
AND MORE PROPERTY IN HARM'S WAY
AND ONLY COMPOUNDS THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE EXPERIENCE ALREADY WITH
WILDFIRE. SO I'M DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE THAT SB TEN DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE EXEMPTION FOR OF
THE SOUNDS THIS YEAR AND I HOPE
THAT- THE AUTHOR WILL CONSIDER
I STILL CONSIDER ADDING THE
AMENDMENT. I UNDERSTAND THAT-
WESTERN CENTER THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND OTHERS HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS OVER THE BILL'S
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON REPLACEMENT
OBLIGATIONS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO BOTH MYSELF
AND THE AUTHOR AND EVERYONE
HERE ON THE SET UP ON THIS
COMMITTEE- AND I. HOPE THAT
YOU'LL HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
ALL THESE ADVOCATE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FIND A
RESOLUTION TO THEIR CONCERNS
BUT IN IN CONCLUSION AS THINGS
STAND NOW I CANNOT SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS-
HE- VERY BRIEF AND JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION
FROM THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED- AND LOOK THESE ISSUES
ARE NEVER EASY AS AS WE ALL
KNOW- BUT YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WE
MUST WORK HARD TO FIND SOME
COMMON GROUND AND HOPEFULLY
SOME SOLUTIONS. TO OUR HOUSING
PROBLEMS IN THE STATE YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT THAT INCLUDES ADDRESS
SEEN OUR- QUITE CRITICALLY
OVERCROWDED HOUSING. FOR ARE
INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE LOW WAGE
EARNERS ARE FARMWORKERS- AND
SO- AND YOU KNOW ALSO I'M VERY
VERY CONFIDENT AND- THE
SENATORS ABILITY TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS THAT- THAT- YOU
KNOW SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAPPEN AND SO- I WILL OBVIOUSLY
BE SUPPORT BILL TAKES OFF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. MEDIATOR TEN MOTION
SOME OF CAN WE HAVE MOTION BY
SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACK IS
SUCKING MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS BOB WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MANAGER AND
I GOT A ONE THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US- IT REALLY DOES AND
THROW AWAY. MY BECAUSE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS COMMENTARY AND
IT'S REALLY HEY I ENJOY THESE
DISCUSSIONS OF ANYWAYS
OBVIOUSLY FOR THOSE OF US WHO
DO HOUSING FOR WORKING THERE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE DO AS
WELL. YOU HAVE TO ENJOY IT. AND
YOU HAVE TO BE PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT BECAUSE OF ME HERE AND YOU
HEAR ON THIS COMMITTEE EVERY
WEEK ABOUT SYSTEM BY BILLS BUT
OTHER BILLS. THAT THE VERY
DIVERSE- A LOT OF SUPPORT. THE
DIVERSE DIVERSE OBJECTIONS TO
ANY KIND OF HOUSING ON OR WHAT
KIND OF IMPACT HOUSING BILLS.
ANY MEMBER LEGISLATURE DOES
THAT LIKE IT COMES TO YOU FROM
A LOT OF AND VERY- I'M NOT
BEING DISMISSIVE RIGHT
WILDFIRES AND SUPER REAL. RIGHT
THESE ARE LIKE BALLOT THIS IS
ALL SUPER REAL STUFF AND PEOPLE
JUST BEING PASSION ABOUT THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS I LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD. TO FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS I'M PASSION ABOUT MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT YOU KNOW BIG
PICTURE- YOU KNOW IT IT IT
BECOMES NOT SURPRISING WHY WERE
IN SUCH A PROFOUND CRISIS- THE
YOU KNOW THERE'S IT'S THIS
CONSTANT. SORT OF. YOU KNOW
WARFARE. ABOUT HOUSING. AND WE
SEE THAT OUR KIDS ARE NOT. I
DON'T HAVE KIDS BUT THOSE WHO
DO. CAN AFFORD PLACE TO LET. ME
SEE PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR CARS
AND WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
DURING. COVERT IT WASN'T
HOUSING DENSITY. THAT WAS
EXACERBATING COVE IT WAS FELT
THAT THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
HOUSING CO TEN PEOPLE LIVING IN
A HOUSING UNIT. THANK OF IT
SPREAD AROUND WE SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES EVERY DAY SO YES
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THESE OTHER
ISSUES YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
ON THE WILDFIRE ISSUE WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY WORK. WITH YOU ON
THAT- AND OTHER ISSUES AND SOME
OF THE OPPONENTS WERE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE MY COMMITMENT BUT WE ALSO
TO SEE THE ALWAYS HAVING A
KNOWLEDGE. THE SEVERE HOUSING
CRISIS AND THE PROBLEMS THAT
THAT IS CAUSING FOR OUR STATE
TO COLLEGE THANK YOU FOR THIS
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WIENER
FOR THE LEGISLATION WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE. AND
I BELIEVE THEY'VE STRUCK THE
VERY BILL DELICATE BALANCE ON
THIS VERY DIFFICULT TOPIC. YOUR
BILL RESPECTS LOCAL CONTROL BY
PROMOTING PROVIDING USEFUL
TOOL. FOR LOCAL AGENCIES SO
THEY CAN MOVE VERY QUICKLY IS
OWN PARCELS IN A WAY THAT
ENCOURAGES MORE DEVELOPMENT. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ENSURING
THAT THE FUTURE RESIDENTS OF
THESE DEVELOPMENTS ARE
PROTECTED BY RECALL REQUIRING
SOME LEVEL OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS. AT THE PROJECT LEVEL
ON THESE PARCELS. YOU HAVE ALSO
ENSURED THAT THE BILL FURTHER
THE STATE'S FAIR HOUSING GOALS
BY REQUIRING THESE UP SONY
ORDINANCES TO AFFIRMATIVELY.
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
REMAINING CONCERNS FROM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THEM. AS
YOUR BILL MOVES FOR THEM PLEASE
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND I
THOUGHT YOU WORK REALLY HARD
YOU WERE MINDFUL. AND
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO GET TO SOME
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS AND SO
AGAIN- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL IN THE MOTION IS TO
DO PASSED HOUSE AMENDED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY I. ARLACCHI OKAY.
NOTHING WILL NOT VOTING BERMAN.
RAMOS HI RAMOS I THREE OF US HI
THIS RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS HI
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL RIGHT
NOW. SIX WILL SIXTY ZERO WE
HAVE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT MR WE
ARE NOT THEY HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH
LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER TIM. SB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU I'M
GONNA START WRITING OKAY I
CANNOT ASSUME PEOPLE. AND EVERY
DAY- THIS ONE'S HOPEFULLY WE
FASTER MY COLLEAGUES THIS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN- SIMPLY
ENHANCES OUR DATA COLLECTION
FOR HOUSING IT BUILDS ON THE
EXISTING ANNUAL PRODUCTION
REPORT THAT CITIES ALREADY
SUBMIT TO THE STATE SO THAT WE
CAN COLLECT DATA ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION BERMAN. ETCETERA
THIS ALLOWED MORE ITEMS SO WE
CAN ASSESS OUR STATE LAWS ARE
WORKING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
SUPPORT DO WE THIS EVENING%
SENATOR- YES WE HAVE TYPOLOGIES
LISTENERS MORE ON DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA YIMBY WHO WILL
BRIEFLY- BECAUSE ON THE BILL
OKAY. OPERATOR LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING THANK YOU. READ. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LOUIS MONTANA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN B. AND A STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN- JUST REAL QUICKLY I
THINK WE'RE SEVENTY SEVEN IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST
TIME A LOT OF HOUSING LAWS THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE ABLE TO
TELL- WHEN AND WHERE IT'S LAWS
ARE ARE HELPING- THAT'LL ALLOW
YOU TO OUT THERE CRAPPIE LAWS
TO BETTER ACCOMPLISH YOUR GOALS
AND ALLOW- ADVOCATES I LIKE
MYSELF TO BETTER REFLECT ON
THEM. AND IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE THIS DATA AND
WE'RE TALKING THIS BILL INTO
THE EXISTING ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORT PROCESS- SO IT'S TO LET
SAID HE THOUGHT THE LOAD OF
COLLECTING THAT DATA ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE REGISTERED TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL SO OPERATOR WE'RE
GONNA GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FOR SELECT THE
AUDITORIUM I SEE NONE- REMOTE
TESTIMONY. I HEAR NONE IT WILL
MOVE TO A WITNESS IT'S A ON
PHONE- REMIND YOU THAT THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER TEN SP FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN. YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. ENSURE WE DO HAVE
ABOUT TWELVE IN OUR QUEUE RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU WE'LL START WITH
LINE'S STARTED LINE SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MANY MATRICULA DIALING IN ON
BEHALF OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
INDIANA FUND HELPING LA AND
DENNIS POINT NINE INCREASE AT
THE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE SIX
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M HERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SAID THE MATTER THAT
I HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE JAMES COOK
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLIND. SIX FORTY SIX. EVEN
CHAIRED REMEMBERS OF THAT GOING
BEYOND THAT THE FOLLOWING
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
IF THEY CAN BE ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE OR THE NEIGHBOR'S
PROPERTY ANTI MISSILE WE WANT
PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY IN THE
STREETS FOR PEOPLE SAN
FRANCISCO YIMBY URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS. OUT THEY CAN
BE AND YOU IN THE ACTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. GOOD EVENING
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JORDAN CRIME BUT THE HALF OF.
GIVE ME. A AT THE PENTAGON
DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY TWENTY TWO
AND EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
NINETEEN. KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN NINETY EIGHT. AND
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOVE ON THE LINE SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ADAM BOOKBINDER FROM
CITY OF CAMPBELL AND DISTRICT
TWENTY EIGHT IN SPORT OUR END
ON BEHALF OF SUCH A AND B. IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND. SIX
NINETY ONE. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS BOB NAYLOR FOR FEELS DOESN'T
COMPANY IN SUPPORT. LINE SIX
FORTY FOUR IF YOU. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS HENRY HEALTHCARE
REPRESENTING SANTA CRUZ GMB WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN TWELVE.
SEVEN TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NEEDED I'M SORRY ALISON
SCHALLERT STORAGE ON THE FRONT
LINE LOS ANGELES HOLLYWOOD BOWL
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK. NINE
EIGHT OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVENING AGAIN KARAMANA WITH
MANTA VMB EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN. THANK YOU. BY NATO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I'M SURE
NUMBERS ALEX TORRENT ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
EXPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
KNOW. EIGHT HUNDRED. PORTANTINO
WHEN THEY ARE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I NAY.
TWELVE MEDICARE NUMBER ELEVEN
STEEL CRANK ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AND HOME IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M. SEVEN SIXTY SIX. NINE
SEVEN SIX SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOGLE LINE EIGHT OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LISA NELSON WITH RESIDENTS FOR
DEVELOPER LAND GRABS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE
PLEASE YOU JUST YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN THE POSITION.
THIS IS ON THE S. B. FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
AND AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
ABOUT FOURTEEN IN OUR QUEUE.
START WITH LINE THREE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EILEEN BROKEN
SUNSET PARKSIDE DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. NINE SEVEN NINETY
FIVE IT GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS PRESS LIKE YOU TALK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN THIRTY
TWO. TO HAVE STUCK WITH CALLIE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF LOCAL
ELECTED OPPOSE. NINE SIX NINETY
FOUR. NINE ONE THAT AMERICANS
SOUTHEAST ANGELES CALLIE UNITE
RIGHT BRING AVENUE BLOCK CLUB
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THAT BIG BROTHER NOW HOW'S
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. FIND IT.
EIGHT TEN. NINE EIGHT TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVE ON TO
LINE SEVEN FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND. SEVEN FIVE TWO.
WIND EIGHT OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING- BECAUSE
NASCO KARA ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE LOS ALLEY AS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN TWENTY
TWO. JONES DINERS REPRESENTING
THE MIRACLE MILE THAT THE
FINANCIAL VALUE OF LOS ANGELES.
AFFILIATED WITH THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE SB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FIFTY THREE. ELIZABETH HENRY
MEMBER OF SAVE LAFAYETTE LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN ANOTHER DISINGENUOUS BILL.
TOTAL LINES SIX FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH
BLAIR SANTA MONICA NEWMAN
NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS OPPOSE FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
NINETY SIX. AMY JUST BACK
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED MEMBERS
RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL VALLEY UNITED NEIGHBORS
ON THE BLOCK CALIFORNIA AND I
HOPE YOU CARE BUT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU DO.
NINE THREE SEVENTY ONE. A
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
OPPOSES SPORTS SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. LINE. SIX OH NINE.
HANA KAWANO LOS ANGELES
PROGRESSIVE ASIAN NETWORK FOR
ACTION AND SAVE OUR SENIORS
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN NINETY. THIS IS
JENNIFER HOLDEN OF THE MEGAN
PARK NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINE MEMBER
AVAILABLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NINETY NEIGHBORS IN OPPOSITION
CONSIDER THE HA YOU. I'M SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE PORTMAN CAN LUCIO AND I
OPPOSE STILL AT. EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU. I KNOW.
EIGHT OH NINE. YES HI GREETINGS
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE ACCORDING
TO YOUR WAY OF KEEPING PASADENA
MOVING HELLO MY NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION LEVEL CALIFORNIANS
LEVEL PASADENA STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WINDS. SIX SEVENTY
FIVE. YES MY SPEAKING MONTROSE
THAT SOUNDS TODAY IN LOS IS
COMPETE THIS IS ONLY A POLITICS
FOCUSED ON TICKET PLANET FROM
OTHER STATE IS NOT BIG ENOUGH
CLASS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ALL. NINE SEVEN FIFTY TWO. MIKE
VAN DYNE CITY OF ALAMEDA
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THE ONE MORE IN Q. TO JUST
BE A MOMENT. BUT A LINE AT
EIGHT SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING TRICIA CRANE
SANTA MONICA SUPPORTING MY CITY
COUNCIL AND HOLDING HANDS WITH
PHONE LET NOT A MCELROY IN
OPPOSITION TO BIG BROTHER AND
EVER BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN HOPE.
BUT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS- A TO
THE OFFER ON THIS BILL. OKAY
SEEING NONE- WE HAVE A MOTION
BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL- ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. FOREVER- THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SENATOR AND I'M A LITTLE
BIT FRUSTRATED RIGHT NOW- YOU
KNOW- YOUR BILL WILL PROVIDE
USEFUL DATA ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOME OF THE
MAJOR HOUSING BILLS THAT WE
HAVE PASSED OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. THE MOST FRUSTRATING ONE
HI WE PASSED LEGISLATION WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE POLICY IS
WORKING IN THE REAL WORLD AND
HERE YOU'RE OFFERING SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
DATA TO DETERMINE WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND IF WE'RE DOING IT
RIGHT. I'M DELIGHTED THAT THIS
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE INSIGHT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
LEGISLATION WE ADOPT. I'M SORRY
THAT SOME OF OUR- PEOPLE THAT
CALLED IN THE NIGHT- ARE NOT
BEING RESPCTFUL OF THE FACT
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GATHER THE
DATA AND GIVE THE BEST PROJECTS
WE HAVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WITH THAT IT'S A
DO PASSED THE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I I'M LUCKY I BLEW
HEY I HARPER ROBERT HI. REGIS
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER REDESIGN
WILL TELL RIGHT. SIX THE RIGHT
NOT SIX ZERO EIGHT FOUR- THE
ROLE LEAVE THE ROOM UNTIL WE
GET THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT AND THE FINALE THE GRAND
FINALE FOR THE EVENING I DON'T
NUMBER ELEVEN SP FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT THEN SENATOR YOU MAY
START. WHEN YOU'D LIKE TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE CREDIT FOR
WORKING WITH US I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. TO SP FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT- SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT IS A
IT'S A VERY TECHNICAL MONKEY
BILL IT'S ALSO BASICALLY
GOVERNMENT BILL. WHAT IS BEFORE
SEVEN EIGHT DISS ENSURE THAT-
TO BE CLEAR SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT DOES NOT CHANGE ANYTHING
ABOUT LOCAL ZONES DENSITY THE
NUMBER OF UNITS THE HYPE THE
SETBACK. THE DESIGN THOSE ARE
ALL LOCAL DECISIONS ON THE FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT WHAT IT DOES IS
PROVIDE THAT IF ITS CITY
LOCALLY THE SIDES TO ZONE FOR
SMALL MULTI UNIT BETWEEN THREE
AND TEN UNITS IS NO IMPACT ON
SINGLE FAMILY OR EVEN DUPLEX ON
IT. BUT IF THE CITY DECIDES HIS
OWN LOCALLY FOR THREE TO TEN
UNITS. THE CITY ACTUALLY HAS TO
LET PEOPLE BUILD TO THAT LOCAL
LOCALLY DECIDED HIS OWN DENSITY
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE A SUBSET OF
CITIES. THAT ON PAPER ZONE FOR
FOUR UNITS ARE FIVE UNITS OR
SIX UNITS BUT THEN THEY USE THE
CONCEPT OF FLOOR AREA RATIO F.
A. R. WHICH IS EFFECTIVELY A
SQUARE FOOTAGE COP. TO SAY WELL
WE KNOW WE DOING THIS FOR FOUR
UNITS IN OUR HOUSING ELEMENT
AND ARE PLANNING CODE. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO CAP YOUR SQUARE
FOOTAGE AT NINE HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET BECAUSE OF A RESTRICTIVE
FIR. AND SO NINE HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET DIVIDED BY FOUR IS TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE SQUARE
FEET PER UNIT IT'S NOT GOING TO
GET BUILT- IT'S- CENTER
HERTZBERG TWENTY SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE REFERRED TO IT AS THE
TRUTH IN ZONING. LAW PREVENTS
CITIES FROM GIVING WITH ONE
HAND TAKING- WITH THE OTHER- BY
PROVIDING THAT IF YOU JONES.
FROM THREE TO SEVEN UNITS CFTR
CANNOT BE LOWER THAN ONE POINT
NO- OR EIGHT TO TEN UNITS OF
CAPITAL IN THE ONE POINT TWO
FIVE WE BASE THESE ON WHAT YOU
WHAT SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE IN
TERMS OF ACTUALLY ALLOWING.
THOSE BUILDINGS ARE TO BE A
BILL THAT BILL ALSO ENSURES
THAT IF THE CITY HAS A MINIMUM
LOT SIZES WE DON'T OVERRIDE.
THOSE BUT IF THEIR PREVIOUS LEE
EXISTING. LEGAL LAW OF DON'T
THE KERR MINIMUM LOTS. OF THE
BILL. THAT YOU CAN'T JUST TELL
PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
BUILD FOR WHAT ZONES ON THAT
LOT- SO COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
TODAY. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPO AND WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFIED. FOR THE RESTAURANT
TODAY AGAINST CALIFORNIA YIMBY
AND MICHAEL LANE FROM SPARK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
LOOKING FOR MISTER MIRAMONTES
AND TO MISTER LANE. MADAM CHAIR
LUIS MARKET AGAIN WOULD
CALIFORNIA BE HERE TONIGHT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT AS A BILL SPONSOR. I
RESEARCH FROM THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FINDS THAT LOW
PERMISSIBLE F. A. R. AS IN HIGH
LOT SIZE REQUIREMENTS. REALLY
DO INCREASE THE COST OF HOUSING
FOR MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING
WHICH IS OFTEN NOT PROFITABLE
ENOUGH TO HIRE BIG DEVELOPING
OFFERED TO HELP WITH. IT
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE AND MINIMAL
WHAT SIZES ARE RIGHT SIDE AT
THIS BILL DOES. I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH IN THE MISTER
LANE PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STEPS TO BURY
PLANNING FOR RESEARCH ASSOCIATE.
A PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK
KNOWN AS BURKE. SB FOUR SEVENTY
AGREED WITH THE CALL THE TRUE
THAN DOWNING ACT BECAUSE IT
WILL REQUIRE THE WHAT THE
ZONING ALLOWS. EXACTLY WHAT CAN
BE BUILT ON A LOT.
UNFORTUNATELY LOW FAA ARE AND
MATCH A LOT COVERAGE
PERCENTAGES AND LARGE MINIMUM
LOT SIZE REQUIREMENTS CAN
VITIATE ZONING. AND UNDERMINE
MODEST CONTACT AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND BILL DEVELOPMENT I
JUST THREE TO TEN UNITS. ARE
PROFESSIONAL ARCHITECTS AND
PLANNERS INSIST THE DETAILS
MATTER. MODEST NEIGHBORHOOD
MULTI FAMILY ZONING IS
NECESSARY BUT NOT SUFFICIENT TO
DELIVER MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING
BILLS MORE AFFORDABLE BY
DESIGN. WE URGE YOU TO PASS SB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ZONING CODES MEAN WHAT
THEY SAY. AND DELIVER WHAT THEY
PROMISE LET'S INSIST ON TRUTH
IN SONY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
ARE REGISTERED BEING SAID- WILL
GO TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE AUDITORIUM I SEE NONE.
WITNESS IN SUPPORT- AT THE
REMOTE. TEST TEST TESTIMONY
SITE. HEARING NONE. OPERATE IF
YOU COULD. ACEVES WITNESS IN
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SP FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. IF YOU-
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE COMMENT
ON THIS BILL- YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD WE GO TO LINE SIX FOUR
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN LINE SIX FOUR SIX- EVENING
CHAIRED THE MEMBERS IN THE END.
THE BACK BOWLING SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
RELATION TRUNK THE BORDER EAST
BAY IN THE ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE
OR THEIR NEIGHBORS. I'M NOT
MILLION BEEP AND THEN CLICK
REWIND PEOPLE FOR HOUSING
ORANGE COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY MD
TREAT FOR PEOPLE SAN FRANCISCO
YIMBY HAVE BEEN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS- STOPPING IN
THE AND IN THE ACTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER SIX TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIX TWO THREE. GOOD
EVENING AGAIN I'M SURE MEMBERS
CLOSELY MONITOR ALL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF OUR COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA AND
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT A YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE ARE NEXT TO
LINE NUMBER SEVEN THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN
THREE FIVE. HI THIS IS ADAM
BOOKBINDER FROM DISTRICT TWENTY
EIGHT THE CITY OF CAMPBELL I'LL
BE UPSET THE UNIQUE SUPPORT.
THANK. OKAY. NINE EIGHT ZERO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. EVEN AGAIN CHAMOMILE AT
NINE PM IMPORTANT AT THE FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE WE HAVE FILED NEXT LINE
SIX NINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX NINE ONE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR HANGING IN THERE AND THIS
IS BOB NAYLOR- FOR A FIELD SAID
IN COMPANY IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT ONE
EIGHT NINE. EVEN IN BATON CHEN
MEMBERS AND JENNA PENSION
SOMETIMES BECAUSE COMING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN
EIGHT THREE. A FINAL GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JORDAN GRIND ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO AND EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THAT BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SEVEN TWELVE THAT'S
LINE. SEVEN ONE TWO. ALL THANK
YOU. FOR MORE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE A NEXT LINE IS
SEVEN SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE IS SEVEN SIX SIX. HELLO
HELLO HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. MICHAEL THE CRY
FROM CASTRO VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SHE. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO THIRTEEN THAT
IS LINE EACH ONE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING FAMILY
MEMBERS SPREAD THE GIVING
PERCENT A MONTH- CAN I VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHT CAN LINE
EIGHT ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHT ONE ZERO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DO WHAT
WILL TRY ONE MORE TIME LINE
EACH PAN WE'VE GOT THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY WE'RE NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE ONLINE ICANN- WE WILL
GO NEXT TO LINE EACH TWO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EACH
TWENTY. A MARKET OF ONE OF A
CAT ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ARE WE HAVE NEXT LINE SIX FORTY
FOUR LINE SIX FOUR FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
HENRY HOOKER REPRESENTING SANTA
CRUZ DJEMBE AND SALAS WE'RE
SENIORS FOR HOUSING. IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER. SEVEN NINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
MILLER CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY UNITY OR AT THE
DMV AND DENNIS LEVINE AND
CREATE ATTY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
L. THANK YOU AND- I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WILL NOW LOOK FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY IN THE- AUDITORIUM I
SEE NONE- REMOTE TESTIMONY. I
HEAR NONE SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ON THE LINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- FOUR SP. FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE ZERO NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE THREE OH NINE. I
LEAN BROKEN SINCE THE PARKSIDE
DISTRICT IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
LINE EACH TWO THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HERSH I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CATALYST
FOR LOCAL CONTROL IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE Y. NUMBER SEVEN
FIFTY SIX LINE SEVEN FIVE SIX
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YOU CAN SHARE
MEMBERS BEING HATCHING- WITH
THE RAINY PUBLIC POLICY GROUP.
REPRESENTING THE POSH CITY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN NINE
EAT. HI MY NAME IS NATALIE
MORGAN STANLEY CEO AND I'M
CALLING IN TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THREE CO
HEADLINE EEK ZERO THREE. YES
MONEY. FOLLOWING AT UNITED
NEIGHBORS ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASH KALRA REFUSES TO MEET WITH
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
NEXT. ONE SIX NINETY FOUR THE
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
ON THAT ON THAT COURT AB FIFTY
FOURTH CAPITAL MANAGEMENT
CALLIE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE A
LOCAL ELECTED UNITED NEIGHBORS
GRAYBURN AVENUE BLOCK CLUB IN
LAMAR PARK WE STRONGLY UPON.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SEVEN NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SEVEN NINE SIX. DEAR
AMY JUST THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND- HAVE STATE
DEVELOPER GIVEAWAY FOR LUXURY
UNIT SO MUCH STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS SORRY **** CENTER WINNER.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SEVEN THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SEVEN THREE TWO. GOOD
EVENING KILLING OF THAT CALLIE
CALIFORNIA LINE BUT LOCAL
ELECTED OPPOSE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHT CAN IT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EACH. ONE
ZERO. LINE EIGHT TEN WE'VE GOT
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. ONE EIGHT CANADA
YOU CAN CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE
WE'RE NOT HEARING YOU. I'M
SORRY THERE'S NO RESPONSE
ONLINE ICANN WILL PROCEED WITH
THE NEXT PERSON IN THE QUEUE
ONE MOMENT. I WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER. SEVEN FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN FIVE TWO.
MIKE VAN DYNE CITY OF ALAMEDA
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA ALAMEDA
CITIZENS TASK FORCE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIVE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE FIVE NINE EEK GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS HOLLY
OSBORNE RESIDENT OF REDONDO
BEACH REMEMBER WOLF CAL. THE
LITTLE CALIFORNIA- FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINE SIX SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX SEVEN
THREE. GREENBERG LOW COUNTRIES
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT COUPLE
REQUIRES MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE
FIVE THREE. LIVVIE HAMMERING
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA FROM SAVE
LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AGAIN NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHT ZERO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT
ZERO FOUR. GOOD EVENING DANCER
CONNOR WE STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WILL RESULT
IN ALTOONA. AS FIRE RAGES
THROUGH THE ROCK VALLEY YEAH. I
REMEMBER PARADISE WHAT HAPPENED
THERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HAVE OUTLINED EIGHT ZERO NINE
WHICH IS NEXT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE ET. ZERO NINE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YEAH RIGHT
OKAY I COULDN'T HEAR YOU
GREETINGS MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT I'M FROM KEEP
PASADENA MOVING HELLO MY
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
POLITICAL CALIFORNIA AND THE
GLOBAL PASADENA THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHT
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE AT SEVEN TWO FOUR.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN'T. HI MERRY GALLAGHER FROM
LIVABLE CALIFORNIAN UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
WHERE IS THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHERE THIS IS ALL THE DEVELOPER
GIVEAWAY THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER SIX FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SIX FOUR SEVEN.
ELIZABETH BLAIR SANTA MONICA
NOMA NEIGHBORHOOD OF. FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS OPPOSE FOR
SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVEN NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE AT SEVEN
NINE ZERO. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS JENNIFER HOLDEN WITH THE
MANGAN PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
NINE A NUMBER OF POLITICAL
CALIFORNIA IN UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT LINE
SIX FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES CAFFEY KNIGHT PRESIDENT OF
THE PARK IN SANTA MONICA AND-
THIS REQUIRES NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO WERE OPPOSED THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE THREE SEVEN ONE.
RECALLED LIVABLE CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
SIX ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX ZERO NINE. HI NICOLE I
DON'T PROGRESSIVE ASIAN NETWORK
FOR ACTION AND SAFE FOR SENIORS
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FOUR FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FOR FORTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING AGAIN THIS IS CANDY
HUBBARD SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE VALLEY VILLAGE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND LOCAL
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TEST BEFORE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE HAVE LINE SEVEN TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVEN
TWO TWO. JEFF STEIN'S
REPRESENTING THE MIRACLE MILE
RESIDENTIAL ASSOCIATION OF LOS
ANGELES AN AFFILIATED WITH
UNITED NEIGHBORS A LITTLE BOOK
CALIFORNIA. STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. FOUR SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE SIX
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX TWO THREE. CHAU TU
WRITTEN SAN FERNANDO VALLEY I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF ENGINEERS FOR TREES WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SIX SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX SEVEN
FIVE. YES MARSICO REMOVAL FROM
THAT SOUTH BAY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE IS THE
AFFORDABILITY BE A STRONG
OPPONENTS. PLEASE VOTE NO.
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE
OKAY- GROUP OF MOTION. OKAY
GERMANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I DON'T THINK ANYONE
STAND UP OKAY- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. MOTION VIA A CELL
NUMBER ROBERT RIVAS. THE SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB ARE
ALMOST. WHICH I TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I WROTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
WIENER US SENATOR WIENER FOR
YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS BILL. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT OUR ZONING
LAWS HAVE INTEGRITY AND
FACILITATE DEVELOPMENT THAT THE
DENSITY IDENTIFIED IN THE
ZONING ZONING ORDINANCE.
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS SUCH AS
LOT COVERAGE STANDARDS IN FLOOR
AREA RATIOS CAN BE USEFUL TO
TOOLS FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
FACILITATE GROWTH IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE ZONE DENSITY LEVELS.
HOWEVER THESE DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS ARE ABUSED THEY ARE
THEY CAN ARTIFICIALLY LOWER
DEVELOPMENT CAPACITY FAR BELOW
THE ZONE DENSITY. I BELIEVE THE
THRESHOLDS IDENTIFIED IN YOUR
BILL OR REASONABLE TO
FACILITATE GROWTH THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH LOCALLY
APPROVED ZONING. I AM PLEASED
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THEM AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY OKAY
AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI NO LIKEY NO
BLOOM HI. I'M BOERNER HORVATH-
HI RAMOS I WAS REQUEST
ROBERT RIVAS HI WEBER I'M TELL
NOT MOVING WITHOUT THE ABILITY.
VOTE IS- BEFORE ONE RIGHT NOW
IT'S FOUR ONE AND WE LIVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR- THEN PERHAPS THE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK ON THESE BILLS THE
SHOULD OF THE SITE. A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH YOU SO THANK YOU
AND YOUR. AND YOUR STAFF THANK
YOU I'M SURE. OKAY YEAH SO
MEMBERS WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
THE AGENDA ITEMS FOR THIS
HEARING WE ARE LEAVING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THE FIRST
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
I NEED SOMEONE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION MOVED FROM ROOM MOTION
OF ITEMS MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM. AGUIAR-CURRY NINE. NINE
MACKEY HI LUCKY I'VE MOVED I
FLEW MARC BERMAN HARPER WELL
MOST. WILL DECIDE THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT RUMORS
OF THEM. OKAY WE'LL SEE ZERO
WITH A COUPLE MISSING. AGAIN
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD COME DOWN
AND YEAH WE CAN GET THESE VOTES
TAKEN CARE OF I'D TRULY
APPRECIATE STUFF. WOULD YOU
PLEASE REGISTER LUCK BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T GET HERTZBERG STILL
LEANING FROM THE. WELL THE-
CLOSEST. NO WE DIDN'T HAVE A
QUORUM AT THE TIME OKAY SO IT'S
NOT HERTZBERG OKAY SO US
SECRETARY. WE NEED A MOTION-
KNOWS WHICH ONE. ON FIVE FIVE
TWO WHICH IS SENATOR HERTZBERG
BURKE DOUBLE INNOCENT
ENTERTAINMENT SYSTEM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SENATOR HERTZBERG FIVE
FIVE TWO. THE BILL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE ALMOST AND THE PHONE
ROBERT RIVAS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS RECORD HIGH. I'M
LUCKY I'M LUCKY ABSOLUTE WILL
FIVE BOERNER HORVATH LEVELS.
THANK YOU. RAMOS RAMOS I
REQUEST ROBERT RIVAS HI LOWER
EAST SIDE VOEPEL RIGHT NOW. HE
HAS. IT WAS SIX ZERO NOT ONE
THAT WE STILL HAVE A COUPLE
MEMBERS WERE MISSING- THE OTHER
ONE IS SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WE
NEED A MOTION FOR MISTER
HERTZBERG THOSE OF- MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. THE
MOTION IS THE BEST
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M LUCKY HI LUCKY
<c.red> BLUE. BLUE LIVE</c>
BOERNER HORVATH WELL MOST.
REBEL SIGNS RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS
HI ROBERT RIVAS I WILL TELL
RIGHT NOW I THINK SO RIGHT NOW
IT'S SIX ZERO WE'LL KEEP IT
OPEN UNTIL WE GET. OKAY THEN WE
CAN GO BACK TO WILL GO DOWN. WE
HAVE SIMILAR MISSING. SHE. THAT
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE.
THREE OF US BERMAN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU HAVE REACHED THIS
MESSAGE FOR SOME REASON. THIS
IS. TO- SERVICE YEAH OKAY.
RAMOS IS ON EIGHTEEN TO NINETY.
NO YEAH HE WASN'T HERE TO VOTE
ON. IS THIS IS A- TWO NINETY
NINE AND TWO HOURS YEAH OKAY R.
S. B. SCOOTER IS A BILL PASSED
AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT CODE SIX ONE. ROMMEL'S
LEVELS. THOSE SEVEN ONE BILLS
OUT. SEVEN ONE. SB TWO NINETY
SKINNER MOTION IS DUE PASSAGE
APPROPRIATIONS. SIX ONE
ROMMEL'S. SEVEN ONE OKAY SB TWO
NINETIES OUT. SEVEN ONE.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE NOW- INFO
IS- LOSE. I THE SECOND TERM OR
NOT S. B. THIS. CALENDAR THE
CURRENT PHONE SIX ZERO
BOERNER HORVATH WITHOUT CONSENT
CONSENT- BOERNER HORVATH
THREE OF US THREE OF US LUCK.
EIGHT ZERO CONSENT. BARBARA TO
HERTZBERG MOST OF THESE DEVICES
ABILITY TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
TURN FORTY SIX ZERO
BOERNER HORVATH I. HI LAS VEGAS
HI THIS RIVERSIDE THAT BILLS
THAT SB FIVE FIVE TWO IS IT OUT
EIGHT ZERO. TWENTY EIGHT
HERTZBERG NATION WITH TOO FAST
APPROPRIATIONS PROVIDED. SIX
ZERO FLORIDA HARGA I.
THREE OF US IF YOU DECIDE TO
BILLS OUT SEVEN SB. SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT ZERO. AS TO. THE
MOST IS THE PRICE OF THE ROOM
TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE IS SIX
ZERO BOERNER HORVATH NOW. NO.
THREE OF US NOTED. SOMEONE SAID
THAT THE BILL IS SIX BUT SB
TENS OUT SIX ONE. WE WANT TO
HEAR ONE OF MONNING OKAY. SB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WIENER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR VOTERS SIX
ZERO BOERNER HORVATH HI. I JUST
READ THIS THREE OF US I. YES
PEOPLE FOR SEVEN SEVEN IS EIGHT
ZERO. THE FOUR SEVEN EIGHT WITH
THE DUE PROCESS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PROFILE IS FOUR
ONE. BOERNER HORVATH NOW
BOERNER HORVATH KNOWS RIVAS
THREE OF US I VOTE IS FIVE TWO.
BILLS UP FIVE TO. BILLS ARE
FIVE TO. YES VERY OKAY SO
DOUBLE CHECK BEFORE. I WANT. IS.
YEAH. WE HAVE BEEN SERVICING. I
GO TO THE FROM THE PRINTER.
GOOD GOOD OKAY. THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU EVERYONE.
FIVE HERE.